[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome to the st louis rapid and
blitz
a thrilling five day tournament filled a
fast and faster chest
i'm jennifer shahady and i'm here with
grand masters
yasser sarwan and maurice ashley for
this great event
hi ji hi jen hi maurice hello everyone
thank you for joining with us and
sharing your day for what promises to be
a really wonderful rapid and
blitz event boy the roster of players we
have maurice
uh i mean it's like murderers row what
do you think
oh it's delicious and it's always great
to have the top players you got magnus
you got naka
it's also great to have the young
players in the event as well we got a
two uh
two under 20 year olds in the event
as well so that's going to make it
really interesting
well jen introduced the field of players
for
our viewers we have world champion
magnus carlson at the top of
the uh pairing list of course and
then we have keep kuru nakamura remember
these two
just tied for first in the 960 event
that ended on sunday
wesley so also in there but we've got a
lot of new customers
yes we have up the pumnichi grishook
favorite of the crowd no doubt and we
also have a couple of
slight underdogs in harry krishna and
jeffrey zhang incredible players can be
anyone in the field
but i do like how there are a
couple of players with slightly lower
ratings because that creates
so many decisive games absolutely i love
those fields that are a little bit
uneven and
let's take a look at our schedule
well um it's very similar to what we had
in 960
but this is going gonna be split up into
rapid and lit so it's three days of
rapid
chess with three rounds a day and then
we move
to the fast and furious blitz chess nine
rounds a day
and our format jen well
what we've got on tap today are three
rapid games and that's going to be game
25 with a five second increment very
similar time controls to the one that we
used with 960 which was
game 20 with 10 seconds almost a wash
really depends on how long the game is
exactly and the points are spread a
little bit differently
between the rapids and the blitz two
points for the rapids
and uh maurice uh let's meet the new
players well we just played a number of
days with
some of the stars in the chess 960 and
they showed their stuff they're all
warmed up but they're going to be four
new players entering this competition
and i'm sure they're hungry as i've
already seen players win money
it's like it's my turn to show what i've
got and let's start off
with the big russian alexander
grishook 36 years old the number seven
rated
rapid player in the world but notes he's
a three-time
world blitz champion so this player is
extremely
fast he's also the number six ranked
player on the planet so he's a top 10
player period
so we were talking about one of the
superstars of chess coming to the stage
he also has such a wonderful sense of
humor
he loves to do commentary as well he's
got his big
coterie of fans definitely someone to
watch as he
is indeed a superstar in this game
and we're going to follow him up with a
player who
many might say he's sort of an underdog
ventala hari krishna 34 years old
the number 32 ranked rapid player in the
world
but make no bones about it he has won
super tournaments before as we see he
did
in 2013 in beale and he's also
the second highest rated player in india
just behind one vishwanathan
has maybe not gotten as much attention
as his countrymen but he's indeed a
superstar of chess
he's been very close to the top 10 in
his career
and players know he is extraordinarily
dangerous
a great genius indeed we'll see whether
or not he can prove himself
here in this event moving on to another
player who's absolutely a genius
the number four ranked player on the
planet janna pomnechi
30 years old the number nine rated rapid
player in the world
he's won many events and certainly
a superstar of the game he has shown
himself
especially to be very fast very
intuitive
he makes quick decisions easily and
sometimes he might not make the perfect
move but he's able to come back bounce
back with brilliant ideas
and show that indeed he is a force to
contend with
remember he's tied for first right now
at least
points wise in the candidates and he may
very well be the one who challenges
magnus carlsen
for the world title so watch out as he
comes to the stage right now
and finally the youngster jeffrey zhang
the young american 19 years old the
the second player in this tournament
under 20 of course ali reza farouja
is the youngest but he is the number 25
ranked rapid player on the planet the
2016 world junior champion this
youngster
this youngster from coppell texas
he has shown that he can fight with the
best of them if you remember he fought
against magnus carlson clutch chest
and was leading at one point he made his
vicious
comeback against magnus can he get it
done at a tournament like this certainly
people will be
watching him very carefully because his
tactical eye is magnificent and his
tenacity
is the same as well so we will see this
is
really a very kind of uneven field guys
not like
straight top 10 as we're used to but i
think that's going to make for a much
more interesting affair
well thank you uh for that maurice now
that you've introduced all the stars
uh jen we got to get to the pairings how
did they match up for round one
well let's take a look yes as these
parents were actually
just announced so
[Music]
whoa post game interview with hiker
nakamura
a couple of days ago that the uh the
actual playoff would be in
uh on the stainless wrapping and blitz
and that it would be
in position 518 which is our classical
chess position
so here we have it um this is the
playoff we were all waiting for guys
i thought you were going to say the
russian countrymen
nepal would be the game we follow but
yeah no i'm kidding of course
wow what a start yeah that is gonna be
really exciting
i i i do though like the uh just to see
some
how some of the young or the new players
who are
not regulars on in these grand chess
tour events
um this is not officially a part of the
tour because it was canceled this year
but the saint louis wrapping and blitz
is generally a grand chessboard event um
so
seeing jeffrey young match up against
wesley so is also quite intriguing to me
wonderful and uh i gotta ask jen what
are they playing for
well a lot is at stake here on the tour
250 thousand dollars at speak dk for
first
place and five figures for
any finish um huge shout out to everyone
at the st
louis chess club and to the generosity
of the sink fields for
making these um wonderful prize funds
available
in uh very trying times absolutely
yes sir i'd like to say uh you remember
the days when 10th place where it was 10
000. no i don't remember those
i remember the days when i i played in a
lot of us championships
and in a lot of the u.s championships
that i won i remember them very well
i won 6 000 that was uh for winning
the whole thing first place first place
and
it was really funny because there it for
there was only half the field wars
awarded with prizes
the bottom half of the field got what we
call point money so it's really
wonderful to look at these top stars
and say you lucky dogs look at these
wonderful prizes
and i'm really happy for the players and
again a big shout out to our fans who
are watching
uh it's because of your interest in the
game that the field
uh is so strong and the prize money is
so great so
it's nice to see uh it
it happening during these very very
difficult times it looks to me like
hikaru hasn't moved from where he was in
the fisher or the the nine lx tournament
jen
well meanwhile um lavon has absolutely
changed locations and he has a new
haircut
but plenty time to talk about that
it looks like the games are underway as
yucara nakamura has opened
with e4 against magnus
exactly and let's take a look at how we
drew the lots well you know i see a deck
of cards and chess pieces so i'm
a big fan of this and uh apparently they
had the players
um pick a piece and that would determine
their pairing number
so that was the six of hearts and i i
i'm assuming aces are once
in this format we'll find out oh
it's one two one no no face cards
let's see a four well that gives you
more whites than blacks
and that was how they did it we didn't
get to see the aces but
apparently somebody got an ace um to
give themselves um
that um extra white in the rapid portion
but of course
um they will be playing a double round
robin in the blitz so everybody's gonna
get at least
one chance against um the every player
in this tournament with the white pieces
and that looked to me that
that drawing of lots actually took and
that took place an hour before uh the
tournament started
uh so not a lot of great prep for the
players
uh by the way hikaru nakamura opened up
e4 which he did
consistently against magnus on the
magnus tour
in their finals clashes that was just
epic
magnus was defending e5 and
a lot of berlin games but today he's
resorted to
the karu khan karo khan on the opening
and the advance today the advanced
variation
is considered the most aggressive
dangerous way
to meet the karo khan bishop comes out
to f5
and ikaru has employed this system
before the idea of this move h4
is to try to discourage the move
e7 e6 because oops
that would drop your bishop
so after the move h4 black has to first
take
a of that idea
either by playing e6 or h5
traditionally h5 is the theoretically
recommended move when white wins the g5
square
and black wins the g4 square sort of
unusual that magnus
has opted for the caracon in a line
that's pretty standard
and he's spending quite a bit of time
already in the opening trying to figure
out
exactly what to do hikara did pause on
the moment
in the move when the e4 c6 appeared on
the board
so these great theoreticians are
trying to duck and dodge each other's
ideas for sure
now am i the only one who doesn't have
any moves for a game
the game between alexander grisschuck
and nian nepomnichi
i'm not going to just check on my board
whatsoever
not neither on mine uh
i only
we know that but gee to start finally he
did move or at least i have something
registered
and yeah but but with no time missing so
apparently with no time missing the
arbiters i think the arbiters are
starting the games at like you know
sometimes a few seconds difference right
um 960 as well
but knight f3 played and we could it
could transpose into a sicilian guys now
i mean i'm
i have to say i'm thrilled with the
opening so far in this round we haven't
looked at all of them
there's a second carol khan and although
i'm not like yes or i have never played
it i do find
the positions that we have today to be
extraordinarily rich
with um advanced variation in the
dominguez um harry krishna game and then
we also have a sicilian
in seo jiang so a really nice round of
openings
absolutely love it that they're mixed up
and we're not just
uh a heavy diet of berlins
this looks like it came from a rasalimo
variation
and the move bishop c5
okay that struck me as a little bit
off the beaten path but uh the players
play very quickly knight c3 bishop d4
and this is the question what is this
bishop that
usually is reserved sitting pretty
on the e7 square is sitting on the d4
square so what
is jeffrey's idea behind this he
certainly cannot grab the bond
that would be a howler as it would
walk right into a pin that pawn is
untouchable
the bishop moves back and tries to
maintain the pressure
i think white will be very happy to play
king h1 and f4
i'm not used to seeing this bishop
moving all over the board
uh out of the opening guys yeah
yeah it does seem like we're getting
templed quite a bit doesn't it
it does it feels uh well it must be an
idea it must be fairy
let's put it oh yeah oh yeah and you
know we know that uh jeffrey is
very well prepared and i mentioned i was
excited to see this game i
i should say that they do play each
other annually in the u.s championship
but at this rapid time control we don't
usually see them face off
right and in fact after the move 92
interestingly or intriguingly the bishop
moved back to the very square it was
on black loses a tempo to
misplaced the white knight and after
rook b1
with intentions of expansion on the
queen side a5
is at least a move i feel i could guess
and the knight comes back to c3
uh again with the same idea so bishop d4
okay fair enough so he definitely does
not want to allow knight a4
you don't want to lose that dark bird
bishop with all exactly
dark squares that would just be
egregious
and furthermore white gets to develop
with tempe
such as bishop e3 and f4 no no no not
the way
that uh jeffrey's going to let this game
go that which is why he played
the move bishop d4 instead
going back to our marquee game between
hikaru
and magnus okay we left it
right here and magnus did play the move
h5
a move that i play a lot in blitz
is actually the move queen d7
the it's a old idea of david bronstein
the idea
is to just uh defend the bishop so g4 is
not available
to play h6 and e6 next h5 is like i said
the theoretically
recommended move and icaru very quickly
by the way
did play bishop d3 trade trade
e6 now bishop g5
queen a5 check knight d2 and a move that
eric
lobron likes to play a lot as black is
to play queen a5
to a6 offering a trade of queens
i must say guys sad to say that uh
i don't see a lot of excitement here i
see
a very closed slow maneuvering game
not the game we hoped for that would
decide the tiebreaker
i got to say also back in the day when i
used to play
sinfully the carrot con thank goodness i
ducked out and
played sicilians when my when i caught
some sense
but when i was playing the caro with
with success by the way
and it's funny i used to play the
caracon and get good results
but i was so bored doing it
[Laughter]
winning is not boring maurice
it was it was just no fun playing those
positions
it's like all the time the guy would
have a little bit of extra space and
you'd have to defend properly neutralize
get that edge get that good end game
you know the bishop had been the bishop
problem had been resolved and so
you get you know you just work it out
you end up winning these games but
and no i got to get into some fire
brimstone chess
and i switched over to sicilian but this
maneuver i learned
very early on and the key for white is
to
not allow this queen trade so he has
livened things up the move c4 saying
no way i'm letting you trade off these
pieces
i'm trying to keep the game sharp and
that's that
that's the sort of boisterous nature
of this last move c4 the knight could
still go to f3 now that is the knight on
g1 it could also go to e2
mind you let the knight on d2 go to f3
at some point it all depends on what
happens with the exchange on c4
and then he can play the castle and with
sharp possibilities yes i think as long
as the queens are wrong
right with the queens off uh black has a
great deal of relief
he he's no in in a kind of a funny sense
black is in no hurry to castle
okay it's like he's played the move h5
which
kind of dissuades you from wanting to
castle on the king side the bishop on g5
stops you from castling queenside
so as long as the queens are on the
board
my king in the center of the board is
uncomfortable
take the queens off the board and
suddenly i don't feel this pressure
to get my king out of the center now
having said that what black
needs to do of course is find effective
squares first pieces
specifically his knight knights this
knight coming to d7 comes to b6 put
pressure on the c4 pawn
uh buttresses d5 that one is easy
the tough one is this knight on g8 this
knight
now that we've won the h with h5 we want
to
occupy the g4 square well not
necessarily
and the real question is where does this
knight on e7 want to go
knight on g8 want to go magnus says okay
i'm going to go to e7 that doesn't
define where i'm going
i could easily go to f5 or i could
capture
and put my knight plunk right in the
middle of the board on the d5 square
again this is all i believe very well
known theory or at least i've seen
lots of positions similar or close
to this one jen and uh i feel that
white has the space edge but maurice is
absolutely right you take off the queens
got no issues i also want to make this
point
this knight on g1 it's it's already
a huge factor in the game because
the knights natural square as we know
often is the square f3
but ask that knight where it goes from
there and you say well
i got no main options like what am i
supposed to do i got the paul
information that's just staring me in
the face
g5 square is currently occupied what
what exactly is the future for this
piece but the knight on e2
on the other hand which is the more
restrained square
has these options you can go to f4 and
go to g3 and after
much thought naka has decided to put it
on the f3 square
to me a little bit of a surprise the
knight was far more flexible on e2
being able to not only go to f4 but able
to challenge
the knight that's currently sitting on
f5 because the knight on e2 would be
able to go knight g3
and ask black what he planned to do with
that knight
naka has decided to avoid the argument
entirely
and leave the knights where they are
again
to me i don't know about to you yes
you're a specialist in the caricom
that knight on f3 seems to me to be an
unusual placement of that piece
very aggressive if it ever gets to g5
but otherwise this sort of leaving black
alone is that knight on
on f5 for example just seems firmly in
sconce on that square
well as a big french defense player as
well as a car con player i've
learned to love knights on f5 and i like
the fact
that the knight cannot be challenged i
mean yes you will have to go
knight g1 to e3 and conversely just what
you were saying put the knight on e2
and you could challenge the knight right
away i agree with you i'm a little bit
well very much surprised by the decision
of
of hikaru to develop his knight to f3
where it doesn't seem to have a future
here by the way just in this exact
moment uh
magnus very very quickly
made a move that i think in a classical
game
deserves a lot of time uh the real
question
is what is this night gonna do and i'm
in my fantasy world i would love for the
knight to be on d5
so i would have really seriously
considered
takes on uh c4 first
followed by knight d7 then if we for
example get a position
like in the from the game where the pawn
comes to b3 reinforcing the knight
i can maneuver the knight to the d5
square now what
magnus did is he very quickly played
knight d7
and uh well very happily
hikaru played the move b3 because now if
you capture there's no way i'm capturing
with the knight
i'm going to retake with the pawn and
i'm going to keep this knight from
ever getting to the d5 square so that
was a very big strategic decision
and i have to say the players are moving
pretty much
a pace so this must all be in their
in their files their own files i think
that if black
has the chance to do it without
catastrophe maybe he's
gearing up to play c5 and that's why he
decided to
um not to take on c4 um and instead go
this route because your your pawn on c4
is still pinned right
you can't take eyes but it's risky with
our king in the center isn't it
exactly exactly at that side i'm not
sure exactly how you take advantage of
it right away because this is still very
closed and you lack that
light squared bishop which can be such a
violent attacking piece right
i think uh this is this one could blow
up if magnus decides to go that way from
what we thought was maybe a boring
position
i did want to take a a quick look at
wesley seoul's game against jeffrey
young because
the opening um strategy here really
intrigued me
um yeah as you were talking about this
little dance of bishop d4
and then knight from c3 back to e2 back
to c3 keep running knight a4
well in this iteration white did play
knight a4 and then played this move c5
which
you know if white is able to get this
lockdown on c5
in a way that you can never play d6 or
d5
um i i think that's going to be a really
nice position for y8
so makes sense to me too jen i thought
the queen
was actually going to retreat to a7 just
to keep the
the c5 square honest and maybe you know
keep the pressure on f2
so a bit surprised by queensy seven
because then you're right
uh white uh bolted down with the move c5
go ahead
what were you about to say i was gonna
say like if black
it's interesting black i think in the
game black uh
has black made a move yet in the game uh
i i'm just double checking
um d6 and bishop e3 were played after
that
on the board yeah so after but so after
c5
um d6 d6 was played right away right
i think castle's first black then rookie
one and then came d6 yeah
that's right right because we have to do
it in a way
i was just trying to look for tactics
like with my bishop and
um my work like if i can play um
takes d6 and e5 and if you take with the
knight i have bishop takes h7 but the
thing is you're you're right for this
moment your bishop on d4
prevents any kind of tactics like that
right right
yeah you would somehow you'd love to be
able to play a bishop b5 jack
and stuff not on tap but
castles on the board usually and i've
seen this
a lot funnily enough of the games of god
of kamsky katakanski's love to play king
h1
and f4 in such positions rookie one
was wesley's choice and well we've
caught up with the play
and um not bishop b3 right so yeah
yeah such clean play by by wesley to me
this bishop has been dancing shuffling
back and forth like it's a waltz
and now suddenly all those moves played
and the dark squared bishop
for white in one move said okay we know
you know you came out to c5 then you
went to d4 then you went back to c5
then you went back to d4 and then you
gave me this bind with c5 and i'm going
to trade you off
with one move bishop to e3
and what did you get for all that motion
that you did
and i don't see what like god well i got
it i need a question
i have one question maurice there's one
cool line which is not gonna happen
because it doesn't make any sense for
wesley to play into this but
suppose uh i mean sorry to jeffrey to
play into this suppose
uh jeffrey plays bishop takes e3 rook
takes e3
and then there's just like some random
move like bad move rook v8 something
like that
um now i can get my idea and take some
d6 clean d6 and e5
and okay i don't want any material but
um i feel like
a big edge with the pawn on e5 yeah i
feel like i made a huge progress because
we were talking about the power of that
bishop on d3 earlier
now it's really a gorgeous minor piece
compared to the bishop on c8
that's absolutely right that would
certainly work out very well for white
but if but of course black is not going
to allow that there there's a
d5 ideas in the position
but okay bishop e3 rookie three i'm kind
of
like i don't want to bring this knight
into civilization by capturing
but i'm really afraid of what you're
wait what you proposed
gen which is to allow takes in e5 i want
to avoid that
so i start to think like i should play
maybe e5 myself to try to
blockage your bishop so it's not on a
great diagonal try to develop
my bishop as well but i'm not
that happy about my position i must say
i'm a
i'm a i'm a pawn grubber but i'm also a
structure guy
because if the structure is all weak
then it makes it really easier to
to grab a pawn and this and wesley
sorry it looks like jeffrey has captured
on c5 and played the rook to d8
i thought he would play rook g8
immediately so as to go with your
argument yes
not bring that knight into civilization
but he has chosen
this move order same basic idea get the
rook on the daylight
and make white be concerned uh
about this rook so here it is he
he actually just he didn't take anything
on e3 he just left that alone and played
oh sorry i'm sorry okay with
rook or he took on c5 immediately he
took on c5 and then
and then after knight just takes on c5
he played rook to d8
gotcha gotcha okay so the bishop starts
bringing some discomfort to
the knight and there is there's some
weird little tactics this knight might
face if
black can get it off uh the queen can go
to d6
and this bishop on d3 will be also on
tap so
he's kind of he's kind of just
increasing the tactical opportunities if
you will with this rook move there's
something concrete wesley has to solve
regarding his coordination here it seems
easy enough
with a move like queen c2 for it yeah
just just sidestepping right yeah
right the only issue there is a knight
could go to e5
and with with the idea of potentially
going to g4
as he's hitting the bishop on e2 as well
and on d3 and you don't want to play
bishop to e2 because then
bishop takes on e3 would be the next
move and be
great like absolutely great for black to
see bishop e2
bishop takes e3 with those double pawns
and the perfect knight
forever on on the e5 square so great
so that's this is get be careful a
little sidestep of queen c2 looks so
natural
move knight e5 you better have a reply
to this one
that makes sense and jeffrey decide uh
wesley decided to play it differently
he took on d4 first and then
played the move queen to c2 not having
to deal now with any of the issues
regarding bishop takes e3
exactly i was just uh thinking that
after queen 22 95 i would have to trade
on d4 to avoid
that variation that you just proposed
with the double pawns here we could
kind of transpose but 95 hitting the
bishop
uh threatening knight g4 could probably
be met comfortably enough
with just bishop e2 again the the one
thing that
i would be worried if i was black is
the split queenside pawns but also the
fact that this
pawn on e6 really is annoying right that
bishop on c8 does not have
what i would call a great view
of proceedings so uh jeffrey strikes me
that jeffrey has some issues to solve
let's just return quickly to our marquee
matchup
against what we've got to say in this
field are the two
big favorites uh hikaru and
magnus magnus has just been winning it
all
uh uh so to speak but hikaru is the one
who's been giving him
the closest run for his money and i
think we're all caught up with the play
not too much has happened uh guys uh
after i think move 10 magnus
burned a lot of clock yeah all the way
down to 11 minutes
a lot of times a lot of times you can
play
a formation and of course magnus is
known to be able to play
almost anything like he could literally
pick up anything and start making moves
which is rare right we've seen many of
even the greatest players in the world
the greatest champions of all time
have limited opening repertoires you
think about a bobby fischer for example
you're not going to pay him money to
play a this is not what he does
he plays night or sicilians he plays the
poison pawn
and he's principled he goes straight
down the line he used to
win at the height of his career gary
kasparov is another one you're not
seeing him just
play random openings he plays principal
lines and go
i mean he had a broader repertoire than
fischer did but still they go for their
lines
magnus can play just about everything
but
you you do that at a risk and the risk
is
you're not going to know all the nuances
of openings like
a person who plays it all the time so
you for example yourself yasser
you at your at your height your opening
knowledge of the carol
may be just as good as magnus in playing
the caracon
because it's where you live it's your
bread and butter
and you're going to know the ideas are
just going to come to you incredibly
naturally
well magnus will figure it out as he's
going along but he might just play some
unusual moves
there's unusual moves tend to be genius
ideas don't they
there's no question that in my day
players simply specialize there was no
way
you could be as versatile as today's
players today's players have computers
and databases
and seconds of coaches that keep them
appraised of the latest developments
you played one e4 end of story or you
played one d4
end of story and today everybody's
playing e4 d4 they've got like
six defenses two one e4 they've got six
defenses to one d4
and uh everybody my day was specialized
until they got forced out like jen you
you love your groomfeld defense and
there was players like victor korchnoy
on timmon who loved who loved their
grunfeld defense
and would only give it up if they got
bombed out
and lost a few games these days you sit
down
and by the way um magnus is one of those
players who in chennai
in 2013 used the karo khan in a world
championship
uh match so he's got this
incredibly versatile um
repertoire of defenses and offenses and
it's really
hard uh to prepare for a guy you could
play
as you were describing it maurice
everything i'd be crying you know you'll
be seeing me
you think you know what i'm just not
going to prepare today
yeah i will just pick him whichever way
he goes
you just want to shore up your openings
to make sure you're solid everywhere
because the guy might just do anything
and what are you going to do he's just
going to choose
pick and choose where the battle goes
i'll just uh
i just remind you a very very quick
story it was from the 1993
world 19 anon vs kasparov was 1995 i beg
your pardon 1995 in new york
where where vishy anand had basically
prepared the open
rui lopez for gary that was his main
defense and he kept
playing it until gary refuted it right
but gary's refutation was awesome yeah
he was like yeah it was like you know
it's magnificent game 10 if you haven't
seen it folks
you've got to see that game one of the
greatest games in world championship
history
in chess history 30 moves or more of
preparation by gary
and that's when you can when you can
drill down and targets
your opponent when they're not versatile
and today's players are
wow by the way jen uh magnus has taken a
kind of
a page from what you've prescribed
opening up the game with the move c6 c5
that totally
uh ramps up the action but he only did
it please note this by the way everybody
he only opened up the game after tucking
his king away with the move castles
castle's knight f1 uh uh
hikaru decided it was time to try to get
rid of that
guy on f5 either with the move knight e3
or the move knight g3
and it was after knight f1 that we saw
the move c5
and well i mean it's 93 right so
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh sorry hold
on yes
okay uh there is an issue
yes with the pawn on c5
so we need to check that okay so we're
sure
the analysis by hikaru is going deep
right now
is what's the deal on the c5 pawn
because
takes trade of queens and then we get a
capture and then
the capture on c5 that's an extra pawn
in the pocket
temporarily although it looks like black
can simply attack it with one of the
rooks and he should be
able to to create a great balance retain
his pawn
and have no issues and those knights on
d5 and
and e3 just look great you could just
trade that off if you do that
so is there a way to maybe change the
move order what if you take on
what if you take on c5 first
right does does that mean magnus because
now
your bishop would stand on that square
if you took and then when pawn takes on
d5 then
the bishop's just hanging at the end so
no nothing to get to regain the pawn
however uh there is a d-take c4 that's
in the position
and that's hitting the queen you simply
look like you have to capture back
and now we take this guy back uh no harm
no foul
and again uh the structure got
compromised there
that didn't work out that well but you
had so we were going down
a different main line and that was uh
that was kind of intriguing to me for my
moment i think we got uh
uh right here i just wanted to see
something i wasn't
quite sure what was happening here
because i do have um
i want to say a very nice square if you
take
maybe you should take with the bishop
but if you do take
with the rook this was kind of where i
was going
could i quickly combine
an attack with rook d7 and knight g5
maybe icaru could end up on the sunny
side that is really tricky
actually i can't find any easy moves for
for black in that position what right
the very next move for black because you
can't compete on the d
line nor can you stop the incursion on
diesel
only at a tempo to play king from g8 to
e8
right right right yeah just missing that
move
though to keep my rook out yeah now i
really
so maybe back here you would have to
take with the
bishop my king would have to go maybe to
a lesser square than f2
i want to avoid a discovered check with
bishop takes e3
i go king f1 kind of a threat well not
kind of a serious threat yes to
do all of this business probably rook
d7 no i can still play b4
so maybe there's a smidge of something
there for white
not sure it's funny you were looking at
grabbing a pawn
you know like it's taking me years
i thought knight f1 and knight e3
was hikaru's plan right you know to get
to eject
this guy to open up uh like an avenue
that this would i think be what hikaru
is aiming for
please it's gorgeous that would be just
great
you know yes sir the thing very
important point we should make
to the audience is that when we
we are in openings right especially in
opening that position you may not
know precisely like this is something
i've prepared
and if we just go back one move on your
analysis board
sure this is where we would sit
every single move white would sit as as
jen
very correctly and astutely pointed out
c5 is the break black wants to make
at some point even if black was able to
get rooks to the file
open file somewhere to the c line c5 is
the break
it's the move that releases black from
the prison
in the position right every move white
makes
if you're playing a classical game
you're looking and going can they play
c5
uh okay okay no okay i'll make my next
can he play c5
uh okay no this stops that kenny but so
you're always looking you're always in
the alert to make sure
black cannot release uh the the bind
get escaped from the buying of your
space when
a cowboy knight f1 it was for sure he's
thinking okay
i got c5 under control because if he
does it then i can just go clock clock
and i'm going to have some pressure
magnus plays c5 anyway you see we've
been having a
long extended discussion on the multiple
possibilities that can be played
and nikaru is still deep in thought
because this move has come
as a shock to him like he can actually
play c5
once and he wants to refute it but his
look at him now his head is in his hands
he's not even looking at the screen
he's calculating at a feverish pace
what to do right now to get an edge he's
not thinking about
you know maybe he's going to be worse in
any way and finally he has captured
on c5 given the challenge to magnus your
line
he has is to take on c4 right now with
which seems just forced what will ikaru
have
can he move his queen out the way and
maintain any that is exactly what he's
done
he's played queen to b1 because i
couldn't see b takes c4 as being
the primary response he would have in
this position
because it just looks so good your
position you set up
he's discovered this retreating move
queen b1 and now we're in it yes this is
some
good stuff guys i'm i'm very very
curious he
must have been calculating some very
lengthy line that when bishop takes c5
now of course
just as you were saying marisa let me
repeat for you
you don't want to take no stinking bond
you want to play b4
bishop back bishop takes
knight takes knight g5 which is why
hikaru kept the queen on the diagonal
and if the guy goes knight here this is
why knight f1
suddenly up makes a very uh nice
appearance
this i mean this is nice if this works
it's an impressive piece of calculation
wow all that time looking at the
position to find queen b1
i think magnus has been surprised by
this move
because now it's his turn to stop and go
what's this he had an easy c5 break as
far as he was concerned
and just take on c4 and get that weak
pawn for bl
for white after white took back
but now this amazing move queen b1
is it good that's the question that
magnus now has to answer because at the
moment his knight is actually hanging so
he can't move it because a rook takes c4
and then he's just down a pawn so you
have to play bishop c5 right i mean
bishop c5 is well of course
okay just a second second i mean i'm not
disputing that bishop c5 is probably the
best move
okay and there i actually are following
our line
uh there was knight d5 uh
and i was trying to this no this is just
this looks bad not exactly ours
he went bishop c5 and b4
this is exactly e7 um instead of
bishop b7 and knight g5 three mate um
nakamura started with knight g3 here and
started with knight g3
okay that's fair enough i mean but it's
odd because
the the thing is what you did when you
took on e7 was to drag the knight
back out exactly i i i the
optimal i wanted my opponent's pieces to
be sub-optimal
so my opponent's knight is on f5 is so
good and then i want that knight out of
here it's got to go
knight e7 bishop v7 97 but knight e3
and again uh icarl probably has some
very specific
tactics uh behind this move i don't know
what they are for the moment
imagine we take the knight
knight g3 that's what happened i mean oh
he did
instantly and then he played rook a to
e8
that's on the board so nothing to talk
about on the board
at the moment so hikaru
hikaru has to follow through on his
great idea
of creating
some terrible looking weaknesses
your subtle threat or not so subtle
threat
yeah i agree and does
does he well he's upon down sorry
maurice you were saying he's upon down
for great compensation or just
i didn't say okay i'm asking
i'm asking uh for great compensation or
just so-so compensation
i mean i could drop a rook on d6 i can
sack a knight on f7 i don't know i could
play
rook f1 yeah true a lot of temptation
um okay but if knight f7 you're getting
just like three pawns for it
right right because if i take with the
king
then you have rook f1 check and that
might be a little unpleasant because
after king g7 rook f8 king f8 queen g6
you're really devoid of defenders except
for that rook on e7
it's pretty annoying but i think that if
you instead go the other way
um at that fork in the road and take
with a rock
um you're left with more defenders
around your king
in fact you can't take with a rook i
think you had
because of the eighth rank you got to
take with right you got okay you got to
get to the other one
yeah yeah there's no choice so now i've
got
g6 three pawns and you're getting your
choice of pawns too you can take on h5
or
e6 um why i like
e6 that's the i like e6 because
compelling first of all is with check
but
also it's like robbing and i mean this
is important
to rob the knight of a support anchor
square on d5
so i don't know i mean um
that's fun that is fun but is this the
current position
we do have any car down to just
under eight minutes uh do we have a
result in one of the games jen
yes we do um this one has gotten
exciting so
exactly glad you should mention that
grishok and
napoli have drawn a few minutes ago
uh in this uh fascinating two bishop
hang game
our apologies to our russian fans as we
didn't get a chance to look at these
uh as you say exciting game uh looks
like a very i love you i'm transfixed by
the nakamura carlson game though because
we're talking about and the thing about
the position after g6 is uh
knight takes f7 looks compelling but
there's also so many other moves you're
kind of just like
try to increase the attack and see like
your rook f1 and then of course knight
f7 is going to be a much
bigger threat right oh and another move
we didn't even
look at either was like something as
compelling as g4
take and you know h5 you know like
chiseling away
a against this defense so there was
a number of uh well i want to say
attractive uh ideas for upon sacrifice
now what
hikaru did do is queen e4 okay
what do we think of that move you know i
don't understand it yet
the way hikaru has been playing is just
so
bold and uncompromising since he played
queen b1
and he's it's as though he's just like
i'm just gonna go for it
i don't care let's go right and this is
this is just really impressive his
pieces are very firmly placed
on g5 and e4 these are not pieces you
can actually eject
like how do you get rid of the queen how
do you get rid of the knight now
he would much rather take his queen and
and worm into maybe eight six but
that would mean you have to move your
knight out of the way first it'll take a
little while
but this last move by magnus he's played
the move
rook sorry knight to d5
and in response instead of recapturing
this pawn on c4 with a rook c4
he's played king to h1
like he i mean he's just giving pawn
he's like you have my pawn you can keep
it
whatever what was was he afraid of
rooksy 493
maurice there was a maybe a tactic uh
i'm not 100 sure because that's a really
weakened king position
i would be a kind of afraid of even
something as
mundane you you mentioned if the queen
ever shows up on h6
watch out uh maybe he was afraid of
knight e3
he did play what you said king h1
and now it's lack unturned
black could well magnus could anchor
the pawn now with c3 and
that pawn is large i guess
even b5 looks playable though like
you'll never
yeah take that on
get it back i will never release the
phone
um now having said that that i think
that g4
and h5 with or without rook f1 included
is a
very a very sharp attack but okay the
players are
really spending a lot of time on some
very difficult decisions
and well i don't know i mean i'm just
looking at this knight
landing on d5 and a while a moment ago
jen remember we had sacrificed and taken
away that
def e6 pawn so that the knight could
never go to d5
this was the thing is white i would be
worried about
uh allowing the knight to live on d5 and
after king h1
b5 looks good but for me c3 also looks
good
and magnus has played the move c3
and who can blame him and saying okay
prove yourself
where's the checkmate you know it's
amazing sometimes
when we do commentary where there's a
round
where the marquee game is almost the
only game worth watching
right i mean it dominates it dominates
yeah there's one board
that has some some real interest is the
game between wesley and jeffrey
and that certainly has a nice imbalance
pawn formation and it looks like wesley
might be getting the better of the
youngster
in this position right but not not
easily so to be sure right but it does
look like he's
starting to get some things going but
it's not a super complex game it's not a
pawn sacrifice
it's not it's just it's just not as
thrilling and if you you can look at the
other games as well
the one with dominguez and hari krishna
for example
what a super blocked affair that one has
turned out to be
so we have to wait to see the explosion
happen and in
the game without eraser sorry that game
though
if you back up on that game that was
bananas the fruits
we missed it because we were obviously
trans picked by but they're i mean maybe
it's
theoretical um but we didn't watch the
game but there were a lot of
uh really funny exchanges here the
ferruga game
yes the first no but i was i was just
commenting on on
uh this game with between
and harry krishnan so this this one
doesn't seem to have had
uh too dramatic an interest now this
ferugia game
there is that's why it did start off it
did start off in a really interesting
fashion with the balance of the capture
on
c4 early in the game so that one has has
been something we've missed
yeah maybe we can take a look at that in
in between the break because those are
some
really bizarre um captures in in between
moves
looks like a very funny game like just
back up real quick because i don't want
to obviously we don't want to go through
all the analysis but just to appreciate
the position
after uh bishop f8 somehow after bishop
f8 you attack my queen on a3 and i just
played the move d5
um both queens are simultaneously in
capture
and let's move d5 it's great queen takes
e3
[ __ ] takes e3 nice
this is the the this looks like the
players are having a
a lot of fun indeed it's like one
desperado after another
like it's not a romance novel here
exactly exactly
very very nice at the end of it we see
an exchange up
so oh really no no no sorry a pawn up
a pawn up somehow i saw rook guts that
can work on the board it's actually even
it's actually even even it's even an
even material on the board
all those wild trades and it just led
into
even material on the board except
there's an even big time beep
b-pawn sitting on b2 and if anything
got round up alareza could be in trouble
but 53 is a threat as yeah exactly
the point of sound so what if i play
knight c5
bishop b3 anyway and now if knight takes
b3 you have this nice
see the in-between moves never stop this
i know in between move
game i i i wanted to you know you were
saying
uh about the marquee match-up somehow
being like the magnet
all eyes are drawn to it to the
exclusion of everything else
and it's like hilarious in my career
literally
like my best game ever was during the
world championship
match in lyon i played a match against
yon timon
for the best of the west right and
i won the match convincingly 4-2 but
nobody paid any attention to it
because gary kasparov played one of his
most
brilliant epic anti-zaitsev games in
lyon
to win the world championship it's like
ah
hey did you guys see my game no no we
didn't
yes there you go exactly exactly jen so
after the move c3
uh rook c2 well again magnus said you're
still not checkmating me i'll put my
rook on c8
queen f3 um
okay what are we threatening with that
move
i really don't know no
rook f2 knight f7 ideas uh
he played queen f3 the queen came to a4
look at this i've been watching hikaru
all this time and i
he was so calm and i'm thinking there's
a pawn
c3 running down the board why are you so
calm
i mean like i'd be scared out of my mind
that attack's not working
right what the heck the guy's just
refuting the sacrifice
this pawn that you let live all this
time and it's turned into
a monster and finally
finally his face broke because he's he's
one who doesn't hide his emotions
and finally the expression broke and you
see
in his in his face now something went
wrong
i am no longer happy with what is going
on and there are
severe problems in black in white's
position
well the problem right is that the c
pawn is just
uh you know gonna queen and
more or or when material or force to win
a material
if um white doesn't drum up some counter
play and i just had such high hopes for
white's attacking chances earlier but it
seems like somehow
he hasn't increased his attack at all he
has there's
nothing that yeah there's nothing i mean
if you go queen e4
remember how we were talking about white
wants to keep queens on the board
and all of these well tr i challenge you
to try to keep queens on the board after
queen takes
now i'm not saying that you might not
not defend an ending but there's no
attack at all i mean the attack
forget about it's not there and
right now i'm threatening knight f7 but
you're attacking my queen so
i have no time for that and you're right
if queen e4 my idea would also be to
play something like knight f7 but
i don't have time and i'm after queen
before knight f7
uh you just take my queen on e4 so no
time
no time for any funny business and i
guess i'm kind of lucky actually that i
have this move after queenie four queen
before
i feel like i'm counting my lucky stars
that i have the rook c2 move you
mentioned yes
exactly right yeah to try to bail
out into some kind of but it no question
about it
it's black for choice big time and
you know maurice you were telling you
know like oh the caracan yeah i did okay
with it i had a solid game
but you know i bored my opponent to
tears and that was how i won
well guess what magnus is saying
look i'm playing a hyper aggressive
hikaru nakamura who's
gnashing at the teeth he wants to kill
me he wants to put some hurt on me
i will play a very solid defensive game
and wait from
for hikaru to overextend and
i'll be damned that's exactly what we're
witnessing i'm telling you i did really
well with the caricon
i mean but the problem was i always
preferred white setup
well even though i was always able to
defend the position
the structure was solid and like yeah
i'm doing good
but at the end it's like geez every game
i have to do this but
but it's the way it was you know it's
good that you learned the carol khan
because if you ever mouse slipped
the c pawn you you'd be okay right right
right right right
uh apocryphal story uh gary kasparov of
course
uh played the karo khan early in his
career and he was very religiously
uh drawn to it he had very very strong
views
and then he published a book gary
kasparov
published a book on the karo khan and he
just gave up
his entire files like all the good stuff
that he prepared and i was shocked being
a karo khan player so i said gary
what was up with this and he said well
goofel came to me and he looked at me
and he said
you're a gangster you shouldn't be
playing the kara khan you should be
playing the sicilian
there you go and
goufeld was right i'm a gangster
i i like the sicilian so much i started
studying it
that i said nah i'm gonna not play the
car right now anymore
but gary man gary was really successful
with the karaoke hold on let's get it
with the play whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa oh rook sack
yeah king h2 um just a second
hold on hold on when we left it rook c3
queen
not queen e2 not queenie for queenie so
sorry
queen before king h now
g3 with what's okay so king g3 there's
queen a3 check for king you're you're
working queen
on c2 i guess what would happen if queen
takes c2
you're going into two pawns down end
game yeah fair enough
that should be enough for magnus most
carrycon players can manage that one
yeah but this isn't going to help too
much so at least now you've got
i don't know but this is resigns
and maca is missing everything he's he
look at him he's like i didn't see that
like that's like what i didn't see that
move
i mean something's gone wrong the first
round of the day for him
and oh and magnus has sacked his queen
to him
really embarrass him because he's gonna
promote that c
pawn and he's he walked away from the
board
and uh and now he's come back to the
board
i don't know why he did it so quickly
but the game is indeed over
he can't because he he just resigned
yeah
and it looks like jazz doesn't have auto
queen on um and we didn't get to find
out as
as as whip piece magnus crosstalk
just kidding i'm going with the queen
i'm gonna go with the lady uh
i keep your magnus carlsen on that
victory and you know
um let's take a look at the other games
because we'll certainly have more
thoughts on that as it's so critical
but for ruja and lavonne that
fascinating
um practical melee is now
in this position it's gone into some
kind of an
ending that's still grossly imbalanced
knight c5 at least to stop the rook from
dropping in
uh uninvited on the b7 square
g4 okay that's intriguing i guess
he's anticipating that and he checks
this king
is going to e5 but after g4 h4
we are just about
caught up no we're not the players have
really
they're playing fast yes
loressa only has nine seconds left
and remember five second increment he
was just playing 960 which was 10
seconds
big difference there um so what do we
got king
s6 and now um black's moving you're
suggesting just play the move
g2 uh g2 but the front the funny part
is i i'm not threatening to move my rook
so he moved the rook immediately
presumably presumably to play check and
to
chase the white king
oh there is a rook check
yes played so so if i play if you play
rook jack and i play um king g5
then i can play g2 gem with the idea of
rook rook to
you're saying after knight g2 and
there's no funny business with my pawn
so no work the six check king g5 g2
whoa okay well actually he played g2
first
with the rook still oh geez h7
what uh check oh no
knight knight g7 jack forces me to g5
oh no then i queen would check no you
have to you
yeah and you can't you can't go there
you have that square is covered
i'm dead exactly oh no that's exactly
what he missed knight d seven
checks he goes you resigned so he was
thinking he was calculating queen queen
right which would have been
maybe right well there you'd have queen
g8 though
but i see okay you would think you
you think that this is what alireza saw
okay that and life goes on probably it's
a draw after trades
but unfortunately he played attack queen
h6 yeah okay
um but he just missed this in between
movers wishing
as they call it it is the round of
switching
wow well an eventful explosive start
as magnus carlson once again uh
shows you know like what a great
champion he is
and wesley so by the way the whole
game's underway
um wesley is in a very nice situation
against
jeffrey zhang you're going to like this
one yes coupons off
in the rook end game um but does jeffrey
have drawing chances
only yasser likes this one yes or
exactly
i think yeah a lot of players you
the audience the guy across the street
like everybody we can count this has got
to be winning
for white exactly two extra pawns
uh these types of positions one of the
things i'm very happy to do
is to bring my king over to the queen
side because
with the pawn already so far advance
it's like you have no time whatsoever
to go pawn hunting uh with rook takes g2
i easily escort the
the pawn to a promotion and again wesley
says yeah i mean help yourself please
do do us both a favor take the spawn and
unfortunately
yeah unfortunately for jeffrey he just
really has no choice
he's got to take a rook c5 check and
rick a5 forces you
back well be careful because i do have
g8
yeah right um i was more of the
persuasion of king before
but okay play brooks c5 okay
and nothing to do here might as well
take a pawn
and i'm assuming it's rook a5 okay
yes we caught up to the players no
choice the rook
has to draw back oh but this is just
lost
with your with your king on f with your
king on f8
i mean on f6 now the white king just
marches up
nicely and says you have nothing to do
no counter play whatsoever your king is
just
stuck out of the action
speaking of nice end games look at this
position with uh dominguez and harry
krishna guys
as a harry christian lovely move
g5 with the idea that after pawn g5
knight g5 and um blacks is black up
pawns
yet yes but he's gonna be up a lot more
soon
this is completely winning completely
yes precisely so it really is one of
those things where
these uh connected
past pawns by the way this guy's still
alive
it's about to play to d2 and these guys
are just dead
so we start with d2 and i think we could
just
like claim that this is over
yeah well now it's three pawns well it
will be three pawns in a second and
indeed it's over pentala harry krishna
wins
um his game um with the black pieces
nice start for
the second lowest rated player in the
competition
and remember uh what a great
um 960 yeah
lanier dominguez has so hari krishna is
saying
you know thank you thank you thank you
very much for the invitation
i'm really happy to be here but excuse
me uh
i can compete as well i didn't just kind
of come here you know
to to show but to really
you know demonstrate that uh you know
i'm number two behind vishy
and i want to be number one in india as
well
so a nice start for um hari krishna
and what do we have yes expected
in the rook and now the only hope and
dream
is that the f pawn is so fast that the
white king
doesn't catch it right
so how would it go so quick into the
game
well all right well this this one
actually
uh the pawn is too fast isn't it
there is the uh there is one
issue yes i can
i mean i i was playing it in the crudest
way i could maurice just
bringing back the king and i think that
that's the game it's actually a game
yeah that's what
we have right now and
if if rook f3 and the king and pawn in
game is a win
then that's really simple because
there's no stopping king f4
to g4 yep so it was literally one tempo
that cost them again and it so often
happens in these endings that it
only takes one tempo to win jeffrey
downs it looks like
two seconds i see
zeros now but he got the five seconds
back
and there's no i mean you got the worst
pawn that h-pawn and you still win ugh
so unfair i know i mean if you could
play king e2 here it's a draw
it's a draw all i need to do is play
king oh
make a game where one illegal move is
allowed in chess
every game and that's your time to use
it is that
thingy too but well when i perused the
games earlier this round i thought there
might be a number of draws but in fact
there was only one
as four out of the five games here were
decisions
wow what a bang we started with well
four bangs
as it were here in the st louis rapid
and blitz this is an indication of what
they brought
to the tables we are in for a treat in
the coming days
that's no question about it and uh again
i mean magnus carlson 2020 is obviously
the year of the pandemic but it's going
to go down as the year of magnus carlson
where he just blossomed and just won
everything
and what magnus just did with his game
against akaru just now
i mean did he make any mistakes like
like i mean was there any second best
moves that he made in this game
and don't say yeah he made a mistake
i'll move one
that's not fair you got you got me i
wasn't
gonna say that no but that move knight
f7 by hikaru
was the shot that he could have played
and that one was sharp and crazy and
wild and would have been in the spirit
of how he had sacrificed earlier in this
game and
not to say that he was winning by any
stretch of the imagination
right a sharp position even here that
knight g3 move we were
a little bit concerned about but this
move knight takes on f7
given that his king cannot capture that
was a really critical moment i think
when he slowed up and didn't go
for it in the spirit of the position
didn't go for it because
because it looked like it it's not
necessarily winning but i mean
you've you've got to play some good
moves from this point as
black and your king is exposed and rook
might land on d6
even and there's going to be some queen
h6 check ideas
there's going to be some tricks that
black is going to have to navigate in
this position
when he waited and played queen e4 and
gave black two moves knight d5
and your move he has c3 that was
that's right and you know king he played
queen e4 in king h1
two waiting moves in a position where he
has sacrificed the pawn
and black consolidated with knight d5
and c3
yeah that was it magnus just turned into
a runaway train after that
and mauled him the rest of the way yeah
it was
all smooth sailing uh impressive jen
what can you say
sometimes you just gotta tip your hat
and say great
great game um let's take a look at our
standings after one round oh we don't
have it quite yet
but like you were saying jen we have
four victors and only one draw in the
draw
was the friendly russian draw yeah
that's right i mean we didn't get a
chance to look at that game too closely
so now
it's just that's just really gonna
happen
well just to have it quick and just just
to get it
just to get it on record that we looked
at the game as well exactly
oh okay yeah so this was um we really
should have been looking at this one the
whole time guys
come on pretty good he's vaccinating
exchanges in liquidations
regrets jeff but of course uh
yeah so one draw one draw out of five
and you know
i think that we were talking a lot about
the 960 event about how many decisive
games there were um but i i
agree that it's like it's about the
rapid chest more than the position
um even even the original jazz position
that these guys
have been studying deeply since they
were five
leads to mistakes in such a fast time
control exactly a lot of decisive games
and
and that game between lavon what levon
played might be one for the ages i mean
it just
looked like hopefully later oh here are
the games look at the results by the way
one point for magnus lavon pentala
krishna and wednesday so so well done
by them to start this tournament off
with a point
um
[Music]
and what i wanted to say also is that
because they're they're the the best
players in the world and they're just so
strong at rapid sometimes it can
actually lead to more decisive games
because
there aren't always trade fests right so
right a bit of a paradox there
as we go on break jen we have something
very special for our viewers a kind of a
flashback if you will yes a flashback to
the 2017 st louis wrapping invest
all right
[Music]
look at gary is on the game phase
preparation
um he feels like he's just getting
started but look at that performance
after a terrible first round loss
he's been on fire i mean draws and wins
that's what he's doing and look at this
we have
finally five no there should be five
checks and let's see if somebody will
finally test him
in a main line no it's h3 bishop g5
g5 or bbc absolutely h2h3
by linear knight takes c4 is a rather
automatic recapture gary considering v
takes c4 but i i like the knight on the
c4 square very much
and he has played b take c4
allowing rook to h2 and that bishop is
is a very he's like checkmated right
he's rightful
he's got to play bishop f1 and that's
what he's done rook h2 bishop f1
oh my so gary just playing a complete
class if you will knight h4 is coming
right
here is one of the yeah bishop e2 uh the
sensitive
f3 f4 knight f4 and then
immediate bishop e3 it's one of his only
good pieces here that dark squared
bishop so he's keeping it on the board
well blacks might start thinking about
getting a very good dark square bishop
for himself
either with bishop d8 bishop v6 ideas
or simply bishop f6 ideas again i would
like the knight on c4 not the
the pawn on c4 because your g8 has been
played and it is a blitz game so we like
scary game but
it's a one minute end game and by the
way with this coin trade it basically
means that this black king
that stayed in the center of the board
never castled is completely safe
and in fact very very good in the center
of the board the challenge for white is
no plan
white has no plan at all he has nothing
to do the
difficulty for black is when is the
break d5
f5 if you can do peace pressure and
somehow crack
one of those pawns particularly that f3
pawn the f3 pawn is the main weakness
here
everything else is defended so if
somehow you can make him move around his
pieces and then you can get at that
f-pawn
otherwise black also has no plan by the
way lanier
i must say has just played so passively
this game he
really did not bring his best and gary
is looking
really great that g5 idea yes that was
good was that good
yeah he hit the next favorite t2 work
takes c2 bishop takes d2 all on the
board and then a quick bishop b6 from
gary
wait a second isn't it that's game on
dropping yeah that's game over
bishop b6 by gary kasparov he's going to
eliminate this knight which is the sole
defender of the spawn on f3
when that pawn falls it's like the dam
bursting
and that's the problem with making these
types of trades you know it would have
happened
bishop takes that forward tempos bishop
takes f4
break there is the move he needed and
now what black is
definitely winning with only eight
seconds left for white if he's got to
play bishop g2
everything's wrong with his game as
gary's just completely owned the game
is that he takes g4 a shot maurice now
he takes
g4 as definitely his shot knight f4
knight and he's dropping a piece isn't
he is he going to drop a piece in this
position
no is his knight's going to be able to
take on d5 when the time is right
94 and
give me another pawn two pass pawns
on the board now for black those f and e
pawns
this is over gary is playing like a boss
and there's e5 here
that just wins the game doesn't it
exactly it looks like dominguez is ready
to resign um
check putting the king back all the way
into the corner or bishop
bishop e3 and now bishop e4 looks
final oh no scrumptious oh yeah there's
bishop away
no that's okay because the king this is
winning too of course yeah no white's
king is completely stuck
you don't have to do anything gary just
push your pawns
this is good two seconds left and his
time is running down
he doesn't have to take this pawn but
why not take it why not that is king c4
and said he's played bishop b5
gotta move king takes and this is
just now he's got a little trick right
on c3 he's just not resigning but
momentum only but
now he's resignable now you cannot stop
the move and there it is
big win for gary casper
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
st
louis rapid and blitz yes what did you
make of that last round
i loved it that was like uh i mean
i feel spoiled whenever i see a round
where
80 of the games are decisive jen
yeah absolutely well four wins and
um executed by none other than world
champion magnus carlsen
um over his co-champion at chess nine
i'll set
lx so definitely making a statement
there as did levon aronian who had
that sizzling day in the 960 event and
what a game i mean i need to take a
closer look at that one because every
time i saw
the game there was another brutal
um and meanwhile end game lesson in
store
for from not not for but from hari
krishna and so
yeah very nice start but that game
maurice by magnus carlson
i mean that was a signature trademark
victory by magnus
and it just sends a shutter down
down the back uh to all of the
competitors
in the field when they see hikaru
getting defeated like that
yes it means you can't hesitate like
ikaru had to go for it
he had to take on f7 in that position
but he hesitated
and as the famous quote goes he who
hesitates
is lost and especially if you're playing
against
1mc magnus carlson he showed
that you need to be accurate to the end
even
in a game where there's very little time
on the clock he's going to play amazing
moves and now we have
talk about amazing some great amazing
matchups
in store magnus versus yaniponnachi
that sounds like a sweet one we're gonna
want to follow
a couple of other pairings of interest i
see hikaru needing to bounce back
against wesley as a big one and levon
and
frischook those two they usually go at
it
that should be a dynamic one as well you
remember the epic battle they had
in clutch chess yes indeed that and that
was oh
down to the wire lavon had to win the
very last clutch game
in order to come back and win the match
that was extremely exciting
definitely and the game of magnus
carlson and nepo has got to be
our feature reminding everybody that
it's
mvl and annepo who lead
the candidates final so nebo is a
potential
challenger to magnus carlson and
whenever you get that kind of uh
nascent rivalry uh gen uh
there's a lot of psychology to
it's it it's not just ego it it it sends
a message to the other guy
yeah you're gonna be my challenger i'm
looking forward to playing you
check this game out as i i want to beat
you
does nepo still have a plus score and
magnus and classical chess
i believe he does you remember those
days when he was like well yeah max got
a minus score
then i think magnus hit him in zagreb
zagre
you were there yeah you're there to call
that action
last year oh so missed going to zagreb
and
had the chance to go to bucharest this
year
paris we were going to go to oh we can
just kotovar
i just hope that things turn around soon
but
yes if you could hop on a plane and go
anywhere in the world right now where
would it be
quick because the games are about to
start i go visit
i go visit gary in croatia on the
beaches of croatia
not a bad choice yeah i would take costa
rica go see my good friends down there
but there are a lot of good choices
there's a lot of good choices to go
but at any rate i say jerusalem but
that's because i have family there
oh there we go an island sounds pretty
good
as well beaches give me a beach uh
okay guys which game should be our
marquee game
i'm favoring magnus i'm favoring magmas
but we need a backup who
who who will be our plan b our plan
um i'd say
that's a car that's a big-time grudge
match that little bit
so enterprising me now look at this
opening this is not one that
i'm super familiar with i know that e45
knight f3 knight f6 has been a tough nut
to crack
the super solid petrov defense but
playing um 3d3 is hikaru nakamura
against wesley so sorry i didn't
tell you the name fires i didn't know
where it was yeah
but um what do you what do you think of
this response to the the pet drop
because
my first indication is if this is the
best line against the petrol then maybe
i'm going to switch to e45 by the three
knight s6
this actual treatment by white by the
way is
underrated i think that in a lot of the
lines of the petrov the main
main line stuff they've really been
flogged to yeah death experience
whereas i do think that the d3 g3
ideas kind of a philadelphia in reverse
if you will
uh something that yogava would really
like
do does allow for a more
creative game like now what if i didn't
cause when when you play d5 because i'm
not familiar with this line at all but
if
when you play d5 in some sense it
justifies the opening a little bit
to my eyes because you know nakamura
then has this nice bishop on g2 that i
know
you love yes but what if i didn't do
that what if i just did something
more like close like bishop e7 and d6
and castles
how was white planning to make sense of
these seemingly
um bishop on g2 that's fighting on
granite and the quiet d3
yeah well it really goes back to
one issue that black is going to have is
black going to play g6
d6 david6 or is he going to play david
5.
if you're going to play d6 well then
white is going to go
okay i'll go knight h4 knight f5 and
i'll play for
f4 um if you're going to play d5
uh like here or either before
then i'm gonna go like knight d2 knight
um c4 and i'm gonna try to target this
weakness and eventually play for d3 d4
it's i know what you're saying jan it's
it's like uh does the move d5
punish black uh that punish white for
his passive play
or does white find it helpful that black
has created an
imbalance i mean breaking news guys
please
take a look at the super solid approach
that nepo
is using against magnus
[Laughter]
i mean super solid boring
uninteresting uninspired wow people with
me maurice
i was fully expecting there to be a
berlin on the board
wow
okay that's that's
that's a visual now with nepo
you never know if that was a kind of an
over-the-board
inspiration or if he actually
had prepared it i must say i played the
english
well if i don't mind saying about
800 tournament games nobody played h5
against me on
i moved three uh in this position so
we're definitely in uh new territory
here as far as i'm concerned now
magnus has actually uh said okay i don't
know if i should laugh
if i have to take this seriously like
what are you doing
how are they zero generation you're
going to laugh at the h pawn
being thrust down the board somebody's
got to do it
maurice might as well be me okay
well let me just ask the question how
serious
is h5 is it so serious that i should
play knight f3
the idea is i can provoke you to play
e4 and if you play e4 then
hahaha i've suckered you into
overstepping and giving me weakness now
on the
of on the other hand if you play bishop
e7
preparing to play the move h4
well uh i've got this other idea
uh playing for d4 myself kind of an echo
of the wesley soul game a bit jen
um this is
weird i don't know i think knight f3
might be the most challenging and
finally
there is the go ahead do what you want
do you really want to do this 193
on the board and an instantaneous h4
by nepo look at how
uh this has gone h4
e3 after that deep
thought by magnus he's played the move
e3 and
i just saw him peek over his shoulder
and he's used his camera
to let us know that he's got a football
game
a big um tv
on the on over his shoulder that he's
watching football and he watched
tennis he watched football basketball
and tennis
looked like in the same day yeah uh
during the during night lx
yeah actually it was kind of funny right
because he would be making
a move that would have us in a cheering
roar and then he turned and looked at
the tv because there was a gold that had
just been scored over there as well
okay e2 e3 magnus is indicating that
look
i didn't want to play knight f3 and
allow the move h3 i'm going to play
e3 preparing
the center break d4 knight f6
on the board and now a magnus instantly
played knight g e2
uh so what do you make of this move is
black gonna play h3 straight away
or just keep that as an option well
i think he has to keep it as an option
jen because after h3 bishop f3
you're not exactly chasing my bishop
back in fact i'm able to stay on the
diagonal
maybe i'm even able to castle and bring
my bishop back to h1
why what if i play e4 and knight a5 just
to continue the line
i guess oh please by by all means e4
stacking upon yeah just like with the
idea that 94.95
right but i guess that in between move
of knight takes
f6 might be annoying but then i play
queen takes f6
i mean uh at the cost of a central pawn
i i
i agree you do win my light squared
bishop but
that's a well i kind of feel
unless you've got some something fun
here
yes i mean c4 is hanging but then i
don't get your bishop so i can't have my
cake and eat it too
hold on jen there's a here's a reason
why
you won the u.s women's title twice
and it's these kind of moves that i got
to tell you i like seeing
and let's see that line you know e4
i just i just want to throw in my two
cents
please do you really need to take the
bishop
what if you traded on on e4 and then
went for the move g5 and just
just went totally hog wild like
c6 against that knight then the pawn on
c4 could be hanging
in some position now v5 is coming and
you're just
you're you're catching a knight come to
e5 and your bishop's going to
be gone without me sacking material
that's what we want
yeah is right yeah but on the other hand
all the way on h1
yeah you you you're kind of you kind of
h3 did shut down
yeah he spent a lot of time playing h5
h4 oh
just to shut it down i don't know
it's look it's even more double-edged no
way
magnus yes magnus did not play knight f4
guarding the d3 square he played his
knight from e2 to c3 so we are seeing
the line
dynamic idea you you brought up jen with
e4
and when i saw it i was like that's some
chess being played
and nepo just channeled your instincts
and said let's
go down this path and this position is
just simply
wild what a thing to do to sacrifice
this early in the game first of all
playing h4
h5 h4 then playing h3 then playing e4
amazing enterprising chess against the
world champion
who was it uh help me out who was it
that was saying that if magnus
was a karpov who was saying that magnus
if there was any weakness that magnus
had as a player
was that he wasn't as convincing as in
chaotic positions
it was kasparov who said that kasparov
who was saying
doesn't like imbalanced positions
doesn't like
positions without even material balance
right
not that he's terrible in them or
anything like that but he's just so good
in every
other aspect right right okay
so by the way the reason i had played
knight f4
as a kind of an instinctive move as
opposed to knight c3 the move that
magnus chose is i wanted to cover the d3
square
and protect myself from check magnus is
basically saying yeah
you can have the check it's not serious
and probably
that's right weren't you the one who was
calling
you were calling this with peter laco i
think
his memory serves me right the game
where nepo
had black against magnus was it in an
english
where he sacrificed the peace after h3
bishop back to h5 g4 and he sacked on g4
and then yeah and then later in the game
magnus blundered or
was it a rook c1 right remembering it
correctly
exactly what a yeah a great contest
thank you for reminding me i just like
i'd forgotten completely by the way uh
jan kind of pulled in his horns a little
bit he said that was fun i i
enjoyed sacrificing the pawn and boy
enjoyed putting you on the back foot but
you know what a pawns a pawn
and jen i just took it back
uh but again i just have to question
what exactly did black accomplish by
putting his pawn on h3 is it a
a a a strength or a liability uh
you were mentioning alpha zero yeah yeah
so if i go d4 so that knight is not
coming back
to e5 it's not look at this
to answer because i feel like it's
partly about opportunity cost like i'd
rather have my pawn on h3 than on h7
because of
the attacking potential but i did spend
three tempo doing it right
wrong where i could have been developing
other pieces sorry to interrupt
just look at this moment look at this
moment right now okay
knight takes on f6 has been played it's
check
king e7 is not going to happen
but but why look how he's thinking he's
i mean he spent some time
when all of us would have played queen
takes in half a second
in an instant yeah i mean it would have
been half a second and he stopped
and and finally took this queen i find
that intriguing
uh that he spent so much time in a
position that just looked
so automatic but it shows that nepo
is has come to the board ready to play
interesting unusual dynamic enterprising
chess
against magnus he doesn't want to make
any obvious moves
he wants to surprise magnus in some way
shape or form
and so far the game has now settled down
to this position which is a lot more
tepid than it was before but
after knight to d5 he's put his queen on
d6
now that's again same spirit
the challenging move queen d6
uh yeah you would have thought that uh
the queen was going to be uh
hurrying scurrying back to the e8
but the ones we want to predict right
the predictable moves
we i mean jen predicted the e4 concept
i think other than that predicting
anything else with
the good news yeah oh no i think a lot
of the audience
knew that h5 was coming on move three
well that was for me a great surprise
okay now having got
here uh i am an english player
i like this long the this bishop on the
long diagonal
i like trading off my c pawn for an e
pawn i like having a little bit more
influence in the center
overall i'm happy with white now that
doesn't mean to say that black has a
terrible position or something like that
but uh black does have some issues this
knight is not
great the queen's not great so i'm
thinking after d4
for all of his enterprising
swashbuckling
things that he's been trying he's not
being rewarded what about knight
b6 here as you talked about the problems
in the position
okay yeah i'm never trading the knights
because not playing because i
yeah i'm not i'm kind of thinking that
my knight has a
little more active
role by the way i also played the move
knight
uh c3 like knee jerk
there's a lot to be said for keeping the
knight
you know as a french defense player and
knight on f4s
and not too shabby either it's it's it's
how i would want to
respond to queen b4 check so i'm just
thinking
and by the way magnus is taking his time
to play a relatively
good he finally did play d4 as you
suggested it took him some time though
that's
that's surprising by the way uh news
alert we're
we've we've heard that uh uh
sasha brought some hurt to lavon
let me just take a look what's whoa
whoa where did that this looks like a
benko gambit
yeah but black okay so black is down two
pawns at the moment yes
but there's no natural move
g3 is dropping the f pawn with check
and the queen is hanging there i mean my
queen's hanging too
but uh that looks tactically like it's
not going to work out well
what about instead because remember you
also dropped the e-pawn
yeah that line and it's likely you'll
drop the a pawn as well
that's what i was thinking what about
king d1 why is king d1
um a horror show besides you know the
obvious i have my king on v1
well i don't know if it's a horror show
sorry the problem is what else do you do
yeah yeah
so what's your other what's your
alternative there's only so many ways
you can deal with check and it looks
like
you have to move your king and accept
what happens next remember
bishop a6 is going to happen yeah i was
going to save it
now i have a measly pawn for you know
having the this
dick this uh ridiculous king on d1 now
if only it were a fish or random switch
back to fish or random and you could
still
then you could castle then we're talking
differently yeah uh i gotta say that
this is like one of the prettiest
looking benko gambit positions for black
i've seen in a long long long time this
is really really nice
uh levon who by the way knows this
variation
really really well remember he was the
one that played
that in this kind of position
that uh peter leiko moved remember that
bishop a5 it from a sink field cup
anyone was it against wesley so
the game i almost had to eat my hat
by the way he did play king d1 um
king d1 on the board this does not
look like a very good position for white
i think sasha
is going to be elated at his
uh sacrifice upon sacrifice once again
when we look at the great players
spending time
on moves that we'd say wait automatic
bishop aces just take the pawn and
playful
play for the great play you're going to
have in the position but there is
one question can it be right if bishop
a6
knight c7 and he has captured
bishop he's like knight c7 as a move
takes f1 oh bishop f1 and then
and then bishop e2 check as the
zwissenzo when you take that's
that's the key yeah right knight c7
and then uh and then this is fun we got
to keep
analyzing this
this is not good not good uh lavon has
got to come up with something a lot
better but now having said that
okay the challenge is there is a
really harsh threat in the position
bishop takes f1
followed by knight b3 exploiting
this pin along the a file sorry
go ahead oh no i just was gonna ask what
if i try to trade queens bishop a6
rook a6 and um queen to f4 the problem
there is you're just going to
slide your queen into f2 probably i mean
happily no way you're going to see a
queen trade short of
fewer material coming uh that although
because of kings positions yes it is
possible to trade on f4 take on f1 and
then play your knight b3 move right now
yes
if you really really wanted to get this
pawn back
and we only get back i suspect there
that he's thinking no i want more than
this
stinking pawn your king is stuck in the
middle of the board what about queen f2
why not why isn't queen f2 just crushing
i think queen oh you just go back
okay i i i i and then i don't have time
for knight b3 because of queen f2 and if
i take on d2 then you conveniently
protect your rocks
now i now you're i'm actually worse wow
imagine that
but um okay uh we do have a resultant i
am hearing
i think oh okay i have a result in
indeed
you kara nakamura and wesley so have
drawn their game um rather quickly
you're only
i think uh 15 minutes into the round um
but i will say that we
are going to see these guys or i don't
know i don't um
i have to double check the field because
it was just announced yesterday um that
the u.s
championship is um going to be in full
swing in october
in fact we're gonna have five separate
events guys uh the juniors
the super girls the seniors the women
and the u.s championship and the open
championship yeah
uh i'm a little bit disappointed i have
to say that
the draw agreed in the final position it
looks like a rich position
to me hikaru i think
still is hot from game one
and he wanted to stop the heart
palpitations or whatever
angst that he was having because this is
a game that three results were possible
so a little disappointment but okay
from wesley sews point of view he just
he had a very nice
draw and so far he's cruising nicely as
one win
and a draw let's go back to our marquee
matchup between
magnus and uh nepo and when we left it
we did see the move d4 and c6 so
something similar to what we have looked
at in the past
knight c3 not the knight f4 movement
knight c3
queen before the queen and the knight
uh definitely need better squares
um a3 queen a5 so now
nepo is kind of happy that he's out of
the way of the bishop
and magnus to play from nepal's point of
view if he could get the pawn to d5 the
knight back to d6
i think he's going to be okay
he's not necessarily pleased but i think
he's going to be okay uh
to my mind the question is uh
if white plays e4 and black plays d5
oops i couldn't actually pardon me that
wasn't a good move
white plays i wanted to say if white
plays e4 d5
e5 i keep the knight from from getting
back
but in fact d5 i can just take so i'm
expecting e4
uh what do you guys think e4 bishop b
for you guys am i harassing
you a little bit you became a pond
grappler
uh no no not at all not at all trying to
keep the play dynamic
we can easily defend this pawn there's
no way i'm going to win it yes
i'm just trying to get one of my pieces
out so i can play for d5 and
potentially get my bishop into the game
but it is a little bit of a suspicious
tight
move a little bit yeah
but this i can play d5 now i this one i
could
try to work d5 okay
um huh that's funny i can't
exploit the well i'm not i'm not
thrilled and i see the computer bar has
gone up high
so oh something something might be
cooking for
for for white in this position
castle or something i mean well then
i i suspect it it i see what you mean
about the computer bar in the center of
the board
there when uh i suspect it has to do
with something along the line that
you know your queen ends up you know in
a terrible
uh uh pickle on there
yeah so okay but you didn't have to go
for this i think it was a little bit of
an overreach but what we have in the
game
is a little bit different what what did
magnus do magnus he didn't
challenge the position with e4 or even a
move like d5 he just
castled quite calmly allowing white
allowing black uh this is not the line
he
on queen a5 he played castles yes
i'm sorry
fair enough and just gave him d5
saying that when i play e4 d takes e4
bishop takes e4 the opening of the game
is good for me in this specific position
as the black king is still
in the middle of the board and a queen
h5 can happen uh
at the right moment of course the queen
is an a5 right now as you pointed
out but bishop e6 now by
uh e6 by nepo
and the rook's going to go to d8 black
seems pretty shielded
the only thing that i'd be really
terrified of
is a d5 thrust yes but it doesn't
look just yet like you can pull it off
and if you don't if you don't get that
move black's going to get
okay well as soon as i said it
if you
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean i just thought d5 was the move
but
you know black was going to he's going
to consolidate
the magnus had the same thought like i'm
not going to let you consolidate
i don't want to go for it is it good
though
i'm just a little concerned about the uh
well here i would i yeah i would think
that the desirable
rook uh d8 actually falls into
some nasty tactic or ideas with bishop
g5 so i don't think
oh no show that line yeah so after rook
d8
bishop g5 i can't play f6 because of
bishop g6 jack
right oh and then you still you have
king e7
well you do yeah i know
i wouldn't go there
but it looks horrible of course but i
like that so ambition g5 is a really
nice mode
so you can't play recreation no i was
going to say
i think you got to play cd5 and i
believe
magnus is actually going to toss in b4
the idea is that after bishop takes now
knight takes d5
i'm i'm i'm uh
i wanna take on b4 so i can go knight c7
chat
okay this one is still very sharp bishop
d6
is playable here oh sorry in that line
that's the same line
knight b5 d6 my knight is guarding the
bishop on d6 for the moment cd5 has been
played
so we're okay we're going down the road
right now this past
so sharp so this is the current position
we're anticipating b4
takes knight takes d5 bishop d6
and my goodness uh
uh jen my spidey sense is tingling but
you know i i'm looking for
like ultra aggressive move i'm gonna
have to rely upon you
uh what do you think queen d4 is that
the most aggressive
that looks nice to me yeah i mean i
think that uh this
this this position looks like incredibly
rich and i also like
why do we have to play b4 we could have
maybe taken on d5 instead
there's just so many possibilities
magnus has character bishop takes the
lightning takes e5
here's a really good 48 type problem oh
i'm sorry
magnus already captured on dean bishop
[Music]
i was totally mesmerized by b4 so i'm
going to work with these
work theater queenside castles are they
well queensland castles sorry i don't
want to do i don't want you to check me
no
i'll maybe i need to do a rookie without
castling then
okay fair enough rook d ate without
castles
and there's a problem right i'm in a pin
uh uh
queen must be like rook you won here
rookie e1 bishop
e7 uh
huh should be e7 it looks like a
ha bishop e7 that's right issue e7 uh
and it looks like i'm having some issues
oh for sure
well he put himself into a self-pit the
only thing i would say
i mean it's a weird move right but i i
don't lose a piece
i don't lose a piece i mean i can bail
out with queen take c4
uh but and you don't have to
but i gave up the discoveries here like
yeah i gave up the two
yeah i gave i gave up the two bishops
for exactly what
i'm not sure uh but rook by the way
if he doesn't play rook t8 if he does
something else
uh this should be very good for very
good for white right
yeah and we're we're in great shape even
material i mean
if you castle queen side now we still
the problem with classical and queen
side is we always have that
queen g4 check move that extricates our
knight on d5 from the pin and also picks
up c4
rugged on the board regularly on the
board
nepo play this opening in such
enterprising fashion
look at that pawn on h3
that pawn belongs all the way back on h7
but it's on h3 right now he's wasted so
many moves to push his pawn all the way
down the board
and after all is said and done
he's the one now challenging magnus to
find moves and
magnus at 10 minutes and change nepo at
14 minutes
and change remarkable this kind of bold
play
working against the world champion at
least
at the moment not saying that it's
winning or anything but for black to
have gotten away with what he's done so
far yes
yeah fortunately i guess you're against
your english
yeah fortune is definitely favoring the
ball this
moment but i am being told that grishak
is still uh
doing very very well when we left it uh
it was queen f4 we were saying don't
trade the queens
and uh well grisham hurt us we're going
to have to
mute ourselves uh jenna a little bit
like greedy
he figured it out by himself i think so
too king h8
have you ever have ever seen a move that
really telegraphs what you're going to
do
i wonder why he played that move well
obviously he wants to play for f5
and to open up the position against the
king in the center
queen see that doesn't stop
well grisha i don't think the move queen
c3 stopped f5 but grishak said
uh well uh more pieces i'm the happier i
am it's your king stuck in the center
and after bishop b7 uh
lavon is saying look at this this fine
mess i cut myself into
i don't want to move yeah i know as
white i really don't want to make any
more moves
i know i as white i want to take this
rook
and eliminate that knight get rid of my
bad rook get rid of that great piece on
d4 this looks terrible
could i be allowed could i be allowed to
take my king and switch it with the
h1 rook yes and wouldn't life be sweet
oh we'd relax if that happened nice
imagination there
mari yeah the only thing like that
i'm not happy i'm looking at this night
and i'm saying i'm dead
i'm dead that night is just too strong i
would probably play
a move like knight e3 to avoid bishop
takes d5
but also with uh the
i i'm not even going to call it a hope
but with the intention of trading off
the knights now i'm probably
it's still good for black don't get me
wrong but i can't live with this knight
on
d4 and i can't live with bishop takes d5
so i think knight e3 is forced
uh while we're on break from our marquee
game let's just take a look around the
horn
it looks like uh hari krishna has a
slight edge
jeffrey uh
this looks pretty even balanced i was
gonna say
ikaro as we know made a draw and what
else
am i missing am i missing some other
games
no that's it you got that's got it got
them all okay we're back to our marquee
game and magnus
is put it is it a pin
well and it hasn't moved in quite a
while he's frozen
on the spot in that place really magnus
yeah he's
he's gotten more at the time of beyond
here
do you remember back in zagreb of last
year um
maurice where uh jan
went on some very early rampage right
yeah
yeah like like great like four out of
five or maybe even worse
and you were interviewing gary kasparov
and you know gary said well has he
played magnus yet
and uh but you were interviewing a lot
of players and a lot of players were
really sour
about yan because he was playing
really really quickly and maybe
not some of the best moves but he he
bamboozled fabiano for example
and here we see him in his element his
opponent
magnus carlson has half the time that
jan has
and it's you know it's pressure really
interesting to see because yes i
remember anan specifically
but others as well we felt like
gabby right who felt like nepo was was
making it making everybody look sort of
foolish
in that he played so quickly and people
and his moves weren't ideal necessarily
right but people
couldn't put their finger on it and he
would just hit you
like being he's such a creative player
such a
natural genius uh and
so his his challenge is to combine that
creativity and ability to
to calculate with also managing his time
on the clock but for him
a part of it is the bravado
of playing quickly i think part of the
fun of the game for him
is being able to do that and when he can
curtail it when he just at the right
moment
curtail that man this guy is tough he's
number four on the planet right now he's
only right behind
magnus fabi and dinglering so right this
this guy's not a
just like somebody who bluffs his way
through the games
yeah he can play like this is this guy's
for real
at the highest level and quite a
challenge so
he just needs to uh figure that all out
and
once once he gets it all together will
he be able to go into the 2800 club and
beyond
uh that's going to be a real question
when i say beyond i mean
yeah challenge world champion yeah
that's what i mean
29 is still a long ways away but but
challenging magnus
and he's shown that he beat magnus in
that in that event what was the event
yes it wasn't
the finals you beat him
i don't know if she was lindoris abby or
was it
was it the legends tournament anyway no
because it was freaky
karu beat him in in uh the semi-finals
see carl beat
magnus there inland and then you know
the game i'm talking about though yes
yes the sacrifice on g4 yes which was
just so bold
i mean yeah who does that just you know
i may be worse but i'm going to do it
anyway
because it's sharp it's wild it's
interesting and it worked out in his
favor
queen f3 i love the move rookie 5 by the
way
just going back a moment i'm thinking if
i'm white i'm begging to be able to play
the move rookie one
so i can hit out with queen c8 check and
pin the bishop
so i really like this move rook e5 but i
must say
queen c5 what like isn't it time to
i don't know bishop e7 and get castle
and get the king out of the center
it's yeah look you would have played
that five moves ago if you could
get the bishop out get the kick get the
king down the middle get the bishop out
get the king out of the middle that's
what we should do get the
and this guy is insisting no i can keep
playing around
i can be solid uh i can come up with
different ideas i can even be aggressive
like you pointed out with the move
queen c6 he does have the two bishops he
does have
the weakness and the king side and look
at magnus hurrying up
to shore up that diagonal let's move
queen
to f3 i was about to say that the move
queen c5
actually really had a huge huge threat
uh of queen f3 and even bishop c4 that's
a nasty
uh skewer as well so queen f3 sidesteps
the bishop c4 uh tactic uh
skewering the rook as well as queen c6
and it has a another nice benefit queen
takes b7
is actually on tap um
maybe maybe queen c5 was
premature bishop e7 castles that's
easy for me to say i mean that looks
like the way to go
we do have we have reached this position
really interesting position you're right
queen c5
it cuts a strange impression but it did
have two threats
the bishop c4 queen c6 so neville might
have been attracted to it because it
just
looks like it's doing a lot but
magnus's move queen f3 sidesteps both
threats
and hits with a counter threat we've
talked about this on the show before
double attacks every time a player of
this level makes a move
they wish the move does two things if it
can two or more
not just to play a move that's by itself
and
this is my only purpose this is my only
purpose right
add points to the move so the queen
leaving the the queen going to c5
two ideas the queen leaving uh
from the d3 square also two ideas
dealing with the threat and hitting your
pawn on b7
why did you play this queen move now
that both your threats are gone
and i'm hitting your b7 pawn what does
black do in this position
i'm sure he's not too thrilled suddenly
that he
allowed white to consolidate in such a
way by the way white is threatening
bishop f4 or bishop e3
getting his game into the game as
quickly as possible
and asking you what you're doing with
your pieces in the center and
you don't want to with your king still
in the center and you don't want to wait
around if you're black because white's
going to develop so fast
well more excitement uh taking place in
the game between levon and sasha let's
just uh
leave it there as well as we guessed
right yeah
what's the most the most exciting game
this round and we were like magnus and
lavon
we usually get it wrong yeah so we got
to celebrate those times
well speak for yourself what are you
talking about i mean
maurice when have i ever been wrong i
mean be honest be honest
you know i'm i'm going through my memory
i know that's what i'm saying
it's hard it's hard yeah
it was 44 yeah yeah yeah
by the way he played bishop c4 he didn't
play knight e3 at once
in order to trade knights he actually
bishop c4 okay development is good
rook e5 now what
i mean i'm looking at all kinds of
nasties
for black and i'm not happy uh
night time when you played nine seconds
challenging the night
oh my gosh i mean talk about blackout
okay didn't see knight c2 challenge at
night
good move uh i don't know
about you but this night
went maybe i guess it was from c3 to d5
to e3 to c2
yeah it was a nice journey oops it was a
good journey i'm not trading my night
for your night and
giving your king a chance to do anything
right i just
i just get the feeling that if you want
to trade
on d4 you can go right ahead you're
gonna
trade off a piece that you've lost so
many tempe moving
meantime i just need to organize
a more pressure on your position right
right so you just want to say
if you're you're welcome to take give me
a square give me ideas like bishop takes
h3
i'll ready to double my rooks
on the open e file maybe queen f6 is
not neces i was looking at you know
eyeballing knight f3 a coordinating
attack
queen g5 also
uh has some some attractive
uh some merit um sure even queen h4
guarding the knight directly so you
can't even win any material on that
square
double rooks yes well also eyeballing
the e1 square so that when you do double
rooks maurice just like you're about to
say
you can invade on e1 i mean this is
something the bishop on c4 by the way
division one c4 masking some
some text right x-ray attack in case
your queen thinks it's going to go on
some journey
watch out because that bishop is going
to be hanging
see this is actually the the problem for
sasha
this is i mean we know he's a time
trouble addict
uh especially in classical chess he gets
mesmerized in a position
this is his problem is he gets into
these types of positions
where it's the embarrassment of rich's
problem right he's got like
four moves that are very very compelling
you know uh d5 queen e7
knight f5 not not allowing any trades
queen h4 queen f6
and then he got he gets stuck
he starts analyzing and analyzing and
calculating
and then suddenly he's got he's down to
two minutes well yes
he kept his cool in this position and
played the movie d5
attached to the bishop very forcing and
it's left lavonne as the one who's
stopping to think there by the way we
need to jump back to the other game
because yeah neville was queen c5 he
after queen f3 he played the move queen
to c8
i can't imagine when he played
queensland drive that he thought he
would have to do this because
your queen on a5 the white queen on d3
and now the shift of your black queen is
now all the way back on c8
his queen's on f3 and then
magnus said well thanks for a free move
bishop f4 rook c5
thanks for another free move knight to
e4 rook
wow maybe he's not dead but
i'm sure he didn't want to do all of
what just happened to his position
and magnus is trying to figure out
what's what's the way to disrupt
this formation before black gets the
castle
well for for for me maurice it would i
it was
huge simply huge that yan
got to win the light square bishop i
mean look there's a pawn on h3
losing the light squared bishop was a
very very big deal for magnus
and with this move knight g5 he's
basically saying i can win
back that trade take off that bishop
and i'm going to be so grateful
to get rid of that bishop my king will
be
safe with my queen on f3 so something
went wrong with
i mean i thought i thought jan had a
pretty clean edge five moves ago uh
this i'm ready to reverse
are ready to reverse uh directions and
say look
this is the type of game that uh type of
position pardon me
that magnus excels and uh she's taking
that bishop
it's gone now he takes on e6 you you
i i was gonna say i was gonna say you
have to i was gonna say you have to i'm
glad i didn't say it because
that would have been another stupid
thing i said but i was gonna say you
have to take on e6 with the rook and he
played
pawn takes of all moves and i'm glad
that's both of you were in shock
as i was like
yes no it was the fisher
nine egg where nakamura's expressions
were like what can you do
what you get f takes e6 didn't see that
move coming
i guess after rook takes e6 he thought
that the majors were just coming after
him with rook c1 and then if you play
rook c6 maybe i'll change my mind and
play rookie one
something of this nature yes no i was
even thinking rook
uh c to e1 but i don't know oh oh yeah i
get you
i i hear you yeah and look at the option
and look what's happened
bishop e5 bishop f6 on the board
but the problem with the division is
that it's a permanent weakness now like
you can never recover from that
now okay so castles i
i i want to eliminate this guy right i
mean just because
uh this pawn's got to go
in europe right and
rooksy two oh sorry sorry rook c2
and i'm i'm sitting there going as
magnus i'm being
so again happy i got rid of the light
square bishop
happy i got off this h3 pawn look at
these weaknesses
okay but maybe for a pawn it's not as
bad as it
they're not they're following the exact
same line
and we see it right now the rook is on
c2 and
what is the situation here the weak pawn
on e6 is
clearly real but we know from these
major peace endings
it's more about king safety than it is
about weak pawns
necessarily you can very rarely win
upon you could attack it three times
your rooks and queen will gang up on
this pawn
but you're never going to win it because
black defends it three times and that's
the end of the story
so so here magnus is saying you know
what i'm going to keep my material with
b4
right and and if you sorry please
memories
and and now black is going to try you
know see we can get some activity
rolling
to try to compensate for the material
deficit
lots of end games could be drawn by the
way it could be drawish
rook end games are notorious for that so
queen trades might not be so bad for for
black if he can get he can engineer the
right ending
right i mean it is funny that these
weak split pawns right um
do at least in this exact moment
compensated
or compensated by the fact that those
rook on f6 is really terrific
but now having said that it is a pawn
and i do have a target so let's go
uh we have b4 on the board oh sorry
it's uh black's turn i
should i should allow him to make a move
yeah
it looks like it might go a little while
as you know um certainly magnus will try
to grind
this to um its maximum while
the uh aronian game versus grishok i
think you know it could end any
any second really wild
um queen g5 just played looking at that
pawn on g2
by the way uh bishop moved to d5
oh that was very that was very crafty
you can't take the bishop because the
rook
on e5 would be captured so queen g5
protects the rook
introduces the threat you were about to
mention jen queen g2
give me that rook and by the way give me
that pawn
and what the hell what do we do now i
mean
knife e5 was suddenly a threat again um
knight d4 was played and then queen
takes g2
that in between move the old swish and
zook again switch
lavon so you live and die by the
wisconsin apparently
queen takes c2 right perhaps the rook i
only can play to
uh e1 or f1 he chose f1
well let's take the piece back takes on
d4 queen takes d4
uh oh geez i was about to blunder rook
on eight
wait no i i can't play it because f1
there's queen
yeah i think we need two but you have
queen f1 awesome
right i was about to say i was about to
plunder a shame on me
putting my rook on pre until i noticed
that the f1 rook is also hanging
so i can play rook a e8 uh
defending the rook um do i have
something
else uh temptation
so i guess you could play taco yeah i
asked it aston answered upon is hanging
guys i can play queen takes h2
and this is a two-minute game because
it's so much wilder
um they've played fewer moves and
because of the increment that means they
have less time
on the clock less than two minutes for
grishok now in just about 220 for
lavon exactly time trouble
is going to become a factor so rook h5
rook h2
queen h2 rookie 8
uh i'm a little bit worried that
if white gets in queen f2 he might be
able to consolidate
um uh grishik i just saw was looking at
his clock his eyes
yeah this uh this is not
obvious i don't know once once the night
come
on once the night comes off the board
yeah
that's what i meant yeah when you're
left with linear pieces you always
wonder where your advantage
like is it is it a long-term advantage
because
linearity often breeds sort of
symmetry or at least a lack of
dynamic play because the knights are
somehow the jokers of chess right
they're the jesters they do
they do funny things to the board
because they're not like these
straightforward pieces
so the whole thing for black now is he
had better
make sure that white's king cannot
secure itself
right at the moment the king is not
great it looks like the queen is
controlling that rank but if you play
queen f2
king d2 rook over then you solve a lot
of your issues he has
by the way he took a long time i don't
mean a long time he burned
three minutes of his clock at least
there with that move rook on 88
the blunder move that i wanted to
suggest right away he took some time
but here's the problem queen f2 the
trick is
that after queen after rook of two you
think you're skewering me
but here i think i get to escape into an
ending where i'm just happy to be alive
and so if i'm white and surviving there
and surviving
and yeah and maybe even king hears no i
don't know
maybe even thriving oh and queen f2
on the board so
uh something feels a little bit the
problem is i can't back up because now
my
rook is well and truly hanging something
went wrong here and look at chris chuck
ten seconds nine seconds and then down
and he's
shaking oh and he's going into this line
oh my goodness
houdini like escaped by
from what was just a tragic position
wow what relief so this feels like
his position oh my god this feels like a
victory for lavon
i am pleased i am sorry i moved us away
because let's take a look at what
happened in magnus's game versus nepo i
thought this game was about to end
but look what happened over here i
thought
magnus was up a pawn and
we we we left it we left it at b4
queen c6 rook d1 queen b6 yeah we saw
that all the pressure was coming on
queen g2
which was our defenses to f2
so nepo did win a spawn back okay
pressure on f2 is so
heavy and i guess the players agreed to
a draw here
wait i'm seeing one zero oh maybe i
think that's a mistake it can't be maybe
it's a typo
yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty not a typo uh
a relay er we'll find out soon i think
i'm hearing that
no it's a draw i mean come on i mean
look it's i mean
well he did have 35 seconds left but
that's plenty of time for magnets
yeah and the position is
solid enough i mean magnus could have
played rookie too
and we're being told
that magnus's computer lost connection
oh no a disconnect did lose the game
oh no a disconnect tragic
because he only had 35 seconds left so i
guess we'll find out
more details from the arbiters but
what a way to lose that opens up the
tournament
big time i thought after his round
one victory over hikaru he's already
preparing his victory speeches
not when you lose on a disconnect and
levon
my goodness lavonne what what what did
you say
uh jen thriving yeah because you first i
said surviving and i'd say well
exactly maybe you're right he seems to
be thriving
not just surviving so yeah i mean he
could he's got a passer
can you imagine you can go bishop a4 and
b4
and get that going yeah look at the
white king
do you remember once upon a time this
king
or lorne on the back rank on d1 saying
i cannot believe i found myself in this
ridiculous state of affairs
i should be in the corner somewhere nice
and safe
why am i on d1 this position sucks this
is horrible
what am i supposed to do and now you're
looking at a king on c5
wow we just saw them chest is out
proudly like
man unbelievable the transformation
in this position that is a good point
never give up on your pieces
you can always be revived right
i mean now he's up upon and uh
thinking about winning the game no
question about it bishop to d1 and
13 seconds 27 seconds guys this is not
the luxurious 10 second increment we had
a couple
days ago a much faster increment
exactly you know the bishop d1 was just
played
um tickling the rook to open up the
the pathway for the uh pawn
and by the way i just saw a little a
little sign on my
uh lee chess board that i was being
reconnected to lee chess
i think one sign as well yeah i wonder
if uh
if i get forfeited what will you guys do
what would you universal [ __ ] universal
bug hitting the internet maybe
uh all around who knows you'll be left
here all alone
uh f5 okay clarifying
uh cleaning up the position what kingdom
three i would have brought the king i
would have brought the king closer to
to the uh queen side so that
i could escort the pawn a little bit
further
uh up the board but okay no harm no fall
i think he's taking his time i would
expect bishop d3 to be played right now
uh as it doesn't seem as though anything
else
is clean wow king again i could have had
the king on c3 it would have been so
nice
what is going on okay put the king on c3
come on level
i mean now i'm a little worried about
don't make me hold on what is the
opposite you know what
yes there is one issue yeah
the issue is if i trade off rooks
as black and use the the light squared
bishop to capture the b-pawn
well the bishop then you make a draw
then i make a draw
so i put this game in the corner this
game is not that easy
if we if we can achieve that trade off
rooks
and give up the bishop for the b-pawn
that's a drawn position and yeah white
has to somehow
make it all happen and what white has
done bishop on f1
backed all his pieces up the united
defending this h-pawn
it's this is not easy at all none the
contrary i mean
black's pieces are incredibly
uh active i want to say and
uh yeah i i think it's actually much
closer to a draw
than um uh-huh this is the bishop
right now wow he's that confident that
his bishop
will be able to to sacrifice itself
for the b-pawn he may be right but boy
that was a big-time decision made very
very quickly
uh jen i don't know i don't know about
you and i
like uh i would have really really uh
well harder to blunder a bishop check
than a rook track yes
because like if you just put your you
know you put your king on a dark square
you're never gonna blend or anything
right now after this move h5 isn't h4 an
automatic to try to say
uh i'm going to
keep your your your pawn on a light
square
thank you for doing that that's not what
was played yes um
let's catch up with the game after king
f3 h5
he didn't play h4 what did he do instead
um it looks like b4
b4 bishop c6 allowing
me to hit you with king c5 bishop d7
now your move h4 um king f4 played and
now king d6 this is what we've got on
the board right now
big decision because this pawn is going
to gallop
quite quickly down the board and there
it goes a king now
on e7 and this bishop
to e2 okay king's going after the h pawn
bishop takes h5
king h4 all the way out
and now problems as b5 is unstoppable
and once b5 happens b6 happens king d
king to d6 bishop c6
and you are lost and look over bristol
realizes it
the long diagonal will be blocked the
short diagonal is too short
the a6 diagonal that is so even if he
attacks the pawn now b6 bishop to a6
that diagonal is going to be too short
for him to defend
he's played king g3 all you have to do
is just push the pawn
bring the bishop on the line that's
going to be it it's
he actually managed to lose a game
that he was winning there he goes for
the short diagonal as we mentioned but
this diagonal is too
short king c7 and bishop b5 is the next
move
and that's it game over unbelievable
unreal unreal
what a comeback what a comeback i love
mom
he used one of his nine lights in this
game that was amazing
thank you he has a perfect score now
guys
yes he is well with the saint louis
rapid and blitz even when it's not in st
louis no that's a lucky tournament a
long ways to go
a long ways ago but we do have
film showing magnus's reaction
let's see the disconnect disconnect
and this is not going to be good he's
looking he's wondering
why hasn't oh now he understands
why hasn't my move shown up
and oh no somebody who was assisting him
and
there now he's saying something's wrong
poor man this is really just this is the
problem with online chess that
other other players have faced as well
and exactly
it's always sad for everyone the player
even the player he's playing against the
commentators the fans
nobody wants to see this but there's
just nothing we can do
to exactly avoid this sometimes
you know unfortunate occurrence it's
just it's a very personal situation i
mean i can say from the experience of
playing
on uh playing poker and you know if you
have a shaky internet connection and
you're playing for a lot of money
yeah it sometimes changes the way that
you play like if you know you have a
shaky connection you might
go all in more often because you know
that that stands right and i'm thinking
from magnus's point of view if he knew
he had a shaky internet connecting you
might be like
okay don't get under a minute because
usually you can figure out some way to
re-log in within a minute
right but if you're down for a second
yeah yeah but i do think there are
probably
like the longer that are the online
chess and even when we do play over the
board
chess again i believe that online chess
will will retain a greater prestige as
we've
figured out how to you know put all the
right infrastructure in place to make it
work and i think that there will be some
slightly better methods for dealing with
disconnections
as this online game continues to grow
i am not the computer specialist i am
quite the opposite in fact isn't there a
way of
backing up or having a hotspot or doing
some wireless
problem is sometimes you have to
actually manually switch them and that
goes into my point of like the 30
seconds like
i mean maybe some computers they can
just like if one doesn't work they'll
the other one will automatically back up
but like
a lot of people if they have multiple
connections you still have to you know
switch to
the switch i see okay well a big
big uh result where do we stand jen
let's check it out well i um indicated
this
lavon oronion sitting at the top of the
table with four
big points the maximum you can get out
of two games
and we've got naponichi wesley and henry
krishna with three points
magnus crossing the only player in an
even score but
i don't i mean what can you say about
his score right now
beautiful game one um this last game
good chance it was going to be a draw
but a loss
the internet connection to blame in that
case uh alexander greenship
horrible start especially considering
his position
absolutely really tough
really tough and uh as we go on break we
did ask the players
what's it like to play online i wonder
if we'll get any
i worry about disconnections answers
enjoy the break
how has chess changed in terms of
openings and even the quality of play
during this time when you're only
playing online
online i think requires
different type of skills playing fast
at times and uh
being maybe a little bit more practical
because
you're you're not really playing against
an opponent that you can predict as
over the board at least you you get in
his uh
psychological uh state
here you don't really know your
opponent's psychological state
so it's more or less about
playing against yourself i mean it's
more
intense it has its own
interesting part but in the end of the
day it's the game of chess
the move the pieces move the same way
and
if you're playing good you're going to
win if you're not
that's life i think there are there
a lot of differences at least
to my game because over the world you
could see
the players reaction every second but
online it is not easy but
of course there are some different
things we don't travel
so much and that is a good
good thing here at our home and
more relaxing so that would make the
quality of just
much more higher i think the quality of
the game is
basically lesser because mo
all online tournaments are based on
rapid and blitz like no one watches
classical online
there's a lot more emphasis on
playing fast and uh being creative
and being imaginative most of the games
i guess
will see a few more blunders because
some players
find it difficult to focus
when not over the board i can definitely
attest to that
being quite tough playing online
sometimes and
remaining focused all throughout it's
it's really hard to judge for me because
you know i don't really like especially
especially lately
i don't really like those quick time
formats i really enjoy
long games because you know you can you
can forge a decent plan
i think the quality of online chess is
quite good i must say like i expected it
to be
much worse i think everybody is is
coming up with a lot of creative ideas
um
people are still trying people are still
studying pretty frequently even if
they're not competing so
i think magnus in particular has played
a lot of original ideas
um and i think many people are just
following the trends of what other top
guys are doing
well i feel that uh the quality is
is not not getting better i would say
it's logical that when you play um at
faster time controls like we have to
play online because there's
of course not much sense in playing
classical
online so we have to go wrap it
and and blades and and there you get
less quality i do feel at the start
in in april people played a little bit
worse
online than they did over the board
because it took some time
getting used to playing online i do feel
in the last
few tournaments that
people are adapting a lot better and and
the quality of play has been very very
high
and i do expect in this tournament that
this will
continue um obviously it's going to be
lower than
in classical chess but i think still
very very um good and it's
it's going to be possible to at least
play some games that you're really proud
of
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the st louis
wrapping and blitz and what a story day
so far ups and downs crazy game
which led lavon to a 2-0 star 4-0
actually considering the point system
here
um but uh of course uh the shocking news
of the round was that
lost by disconnection for magnus carls
and i'm sure we'll find out the full
story about that later
but uh meanwhile here are the standings
um lebron on a perfect 4-0 and three
players
right behind him with three uh by virtue
of winning and drawing a game again just
as jen was
mentioning in this format of blitz and
rapid
it's a double waiting for the rapid
games and that's the 4-0 score
uh wow uh
you both remember in the magnus carlson
tour the fairness factor magnus carlson
won against digler and when his opponent
disconnected
magnus contrived to lose the following
game in five moves
uh to give back the point but that was
match play
nobody in this tournament is going to
give magnus uh the point back that's
that point is gone and uh we just move
on to round three and say
uh tough luck well this is round three
pairings by the way as
an angry magnus carlson will be facing
wesley so
with the black pieces um and our
tournament leader levon
ronian playing against another
frontrunner after
that disconnect although credit jayan he
also did play very enterprisingly in
that game
so that's the game with the most points
in the tournament right now
exactly i gotta feel
what to him what's this is he shaving
you're not allowed to be shaving
but you know the thing the thing that
that's really sad when that happens
and i've seen it happen in other
broadcasts and i'm always multiple times
yeah
it's like oh man that's rough on your
broadcast
you're watching the fans are just
frustrated
magnus's fans are frustrated nepo's fans
are shrugging their shoulders
you know maybe we got we got to win but
nobody's going to give him any kudos for
for that kind of victory but it's also
the players
magnus needing to bounce back and even
nepo saying what am i supposed to do
it's not my fault it can't definitely
not his fault
but he you feel like you were battling
you're trying to prove
this compensation being a hard tough
fighter that he is
you know gladiator chest getting that
drawn position and
maybe looking for some possibilities and
then all of a sudden
you're like ugh instead of getting
credit for my fighting spirit
is going to be known as the game that
magnus disconnected
not the game that i played so
enterprisingly and well
to get even to that position so it
overrides the play becomes the whole
story of the game and that's what's
going to be written about
right that's that's what we're talking
about that's going to be written about
that's going to go on record
magnus disconnected and that's it so it
really
it's just one of those things that
leaves that sour taste in your mouth and
what what can you do this is this is the
world we're living in at the moment
exactly you got to clear your head and
just come back
fresh for this round three and game uh
guys uh what
uh what what's our marquee game here
we've got
wesley versus magnus and of course our
front runner uh levon aronian
is playing against jan so we've got two
i think lavon and obviously i want to
see how magnus plays after that
highly unfortunate incident but i i feel
like lavon and jan is going to be a
great game i mean exciting
just if we look at how fast and
and exciting he plays um so i i'm i
don't know i mean he's gonna play for
an early age we're in this game
perhaps perhaps but uh okay we saw what
hikaru did maurice
uh after he lost game one against magnus
he came back and made a quick draw
you think that's in is that who
magnus carlson is just say
well that was a ha no that's not the
world champion
that's not what defines magnus carlsen
uh no
hopping mad is the word right now and i
think if the same thing had happened to
hikaru
he would have been hopping mad as well
it's not the loss
it's the way you lose so hikaru lost a
game where
he wasn't quite seeing the boy you could
tell he was he made a movie he was
what i didn't see that either so i think
he has to
clear his head in the next game just to
right the ship get the mind right
something was a bit off and he realized
it because those are not moves he
normally misses
uh the way he lost is just not he carol
nakamura magnus didn't lose that way
he lost in a very different fashion he
lost because of a disconnect
so there's no reason for him to think
i'm not playing well i'm playing badly
he's just
he's just going to go in with a
completely different attitude you know
i'm also intrigued by
the camera uh showing nepo's reaction to
magnus's loss
and or his victory i'd be intrigued by
that if we could pull up that
somewhere if it exists yeah
if we do have it to see how he responded
because that would tell us a little
something about
what nipple felt about that round but i
do believe that
nepo aronian to me is the marquee game
of this round too well there it is it's
e4 e5
the games have begun right if it's a
berlin though we're leaving it
okay no i was about to say it was going
to be a scotch i was 100
sure that nepo was going to play d4
as he frequently does on move three
instead he played g3
and he carries choice exactly i wanted
to say against the petrol very good yes
before does this have this kind of um
scandinavian type feel where black's
gonna castle along
doesn't it uh it's almost what they call
the center
counter where the queen somehow gets on
e6 but no uh
we're not going in that direction at all
h3 bishop h5 on the board
and levon is playing this very quickly
as if
it's a part of his prep and for
for me we're in very unfamiliar
territory
yeah this looks very strange this
position already
like getting more than he deserves in
some ways
until you see this move land g4 d3
what a sharp way of handling this so far
by white although it could settle down
in that unless unless black does a pawn
press of some kind like an h5
idea which i think is probably
mistimed at the moment i think just uh
go happily bishop hunting here with a
move like knight h4
in fact what i wanted to say is this
bishop on g2
is so awesomely powerful on this open
diagonal that
that bishop hunting with knight h4 takes
g6
is something i would really really want
to do
as white and as black i might even
go so far as to suggest bishop e7 just
just stop at that idea
which isn't exactly great um something
about this position
i prefer i like white yeah that's what i
was gonna say
that sorry the way the way this game is
gone
it's like if white settles the position
down
then black has to deal with this this
nice space that white is having
but i can black keep the energy up
somehow i don't see how to do it though
i can't
i mean you're right f5 h5 ideas they
just look
all awfully mis-timed yes you can like
in center
counter gambits fashion you can castle
great you've got great control over d4
but
i'm i'm not about to fight you on
the d4 square i'll just play like you
play bishop e3 here
no i i'm hunting that bishop i'm taking
that bishop
and just you know planting a knight on
e4 but yes you're right
i will play for bishop e3 and maybe f4
as well
by the way we do have the move knight e7
i'm still hunting that bishop i'm still
playing this move
i may not take it immediately but i want
to play knight h4
castle and f4 and you'll take it once
provoked so if i play f6 or f5 or
you should basically and you'll take it
right exactly once you make
some type of move that suggests oh this
bishop
is going to slip from my grasp then i'll
just take it
and uh well i guess you can take it
either way but at the end of the day
i've got this
nice control over the e4 square light
squares by the way bishop
e3 immediately by jan he says i'm in no
hurry to hunt your bishop
i too may play queen d2 and castle's
long
i like it this is a very imbalanced game
and i think this is going to be
uh a game to keep a careful eye on let's
just quickly
settle in and see what wesley so has
done against magnus oh my
we have an open sicilian but this time
with queen takes d4
different move order to get us into this
uh moment
yeah from bishop b5 check in the
beginning of the game
this one well it looks like a nice
setup of cheveningen set up
fine perfectly okay your interesting
positions is black right yes
yes yes i've always i've always liked
hedgehogs type structures but i always
like
these pawns that cover a lot of squares
uh along you know the fifth rank
uh and restrain the opponent just kind
of keep
them at arm's length and i've always
liked to have open c
file for operations that's why i'm an
english uh
fan and like an interesting odds game to
do that you wouldn't have to change any
programming for and i got this idea
partly by reading about the alpha zero
experiments
yes um is okay uh i i can make any kind
of pawn move in the first move two
two squares or one you can only make one
square upon those
oh yeah just like an interesting way to
give odds right
because your opening play would be um
heavily constrained and
poor pawns attacks would be very
powerful yeah
whereas yes exactly you you get a lot of
space very quickly so you're
doing it willingly that's that was my
point it's like you're not getting odds
to do this you wanted to do it
because right it allows you this kind of
great counter attacking and potential
later in the game maurice what about you
if you had to pick a side here
um based on your style with who would
you play
both you're excited about the position
for both players yeah absolutely i think
the difficulty for white is usually that
knight on f3
because you want the knight to be out of
the way so you can play for f4
and get get those ponies going some
action so i do believe
that black is perfectly okay in a setup
like this one
but white will be moving the night off
of f3 at some point because there's
nothing else to do like just zero else
to do in the position that makes
any real sense and you're gonna have to
get your f pawn
going up the board so knight d2 is an
interesting move for sure
i don't see i just want to watch my
queen
sitting on d right d4 to make sure it
doesn't
get caught by some kind of weird trap
with the e5 somehow or even d5
bishop c5 ideas could come right
so that was what i was trying to guess
where magnus was going
uh you know i would play the bishop to
e7 in a blitz or a bullet game
is he thinking to himself that
he could play hyper aggressively
with a d5 pawn takes bishop c5
something of this nature is he
calculating those kinds of lines or
you're totally different your biggest
worry here yeah
from a sicilian standpoint is if d5 the
move e5
you have to wonder about because your
knight
doesn't have any easy squares and so
this can be met by queen f4
i still got the bishop on b7
kind of x-ray protection and then trade
on e4
and knight g5 i tell you what i'll do
oh can i take on oh
maybe not okay uh knight g5 yep yep yep
yep yep okay
gotta get outta dodge so
i'm i'm thinking that i wanna take on e3
and if you take with the pawn
okay i'm not at all unhappy
so now if we just play rook sorry bishop
takes c5
yep playing to rook here maybe i don't
know
yep
see what will grow once you plant the
rook on the board
you know okay yeah you never know right
uh
in that position there was also a b4
possibility
very wild well indeed because
in my mind maurice what i was hoping to
do with black was to play
h6 and if the knight is forced away to
h3
then we're unhappy with white right so
if you go b4
one of the one of the lines
that we might end up you know trying to
calculate
ourselves is what's happening in this
kind of a crazy
bottom line uh bishop on b7 is not
bad uh but okay this is
conjecture on our part i mean as black
with my king still stuck in the center i
wouldn't want to play d5 that early
i'm just trying to guess why isn't
magnus instantly
uh dropping bishop e7 on the board do
you
do you have an alternative for magnus
than bishop e7 or d5
i think it is d5 yeah i think d5 is
probably what he's looking at very very
carefully
okay if he gets it then then black is
supposed to be fine
right the other thing though a moment
ago you were saying the knight on
on f3 is like oh why did you put your
knight on f3 if you're going to play d5
aren't you kind of helping white a
little bit so
now my knight on f3 doesn't feel so bad
right
i mean sure you can get this but
i think that the knight
can uh be happy uh
on f3 a moment ago maybe it was less i'm
worried though yes
because yeah d5 takes when you play
bishop c5
your king side gets a little strange
uh so
but can i allow bishop e3 is the
question
you mean you want to go queen h4 and
kind of just
snoop around on the king side a little
bit oh here you could take here
that is a good point so i was actually
just going to take this back
right and then if i take on d5 you take
okay so now you haven't you haven't cast
i'm still
no i and i'm really anxious to
uh to get my king out of dodge
yeah right so even here maybe the move
bishop to f4
calls itself uh
presents itself as a possibility and
you know and there's a there's a little
rook uh
d well this move i can play c4
maybe i start with some crazy
i actually even want to play b4
feeling myself well you kind of got in
that
you kind of got in that mode of a tiger
remember hikaru got himself in that
hyper
mode of like let me go kill the world
champion
and sacrifice a pawn to uh
i got nothing uh yeah it's interesting
attack the
the g-pawn like queen g5 or something
and right
another yeah you know you it's gonna be
a
very tricky very absolutely
great games on tap again and i really
just love that magnus
came out of the gate after that
disappointment um by playing the
sicilian
because you know he wants to try to
leave a
nicer taste in his mouth than that
disconnect guys
exactly and by the way just to remind
everybody we're playing three rapid
games we're in the third round
so this will be the last game of the day
and magnus definitely doesn't want to
end it on
a double double sour note again if he
hasn't
decided on d5 by now he really
i'm sorry this is clock mismanagement
maybe egregious maybe he's having
i dare i say maybe he's having computer
problems
well let's hope now i don't have any
information about that that was just a
joke
i just want to say you you know you got
25 minutes at the start of the game
in a very non-complicated position this
is not
this is just out of the opening i just
don't think you can burn 10 minutes
that'll come back and you could really
uh
well you could simply lose the game not
having sufficient time
for when you well it is magnus carlsen
you can often recover
even from that but you know the other
super interesting game at the top of
this yes please
um between napoli and lavon
we we left i think around 92.
so not too many more moves have been
played but i mean just look at how rich
this is
um with the the kings on opposite sides
well soon to be opposite sides
knight b3 and now f5
and knight b3 and uh looking at that c5
square
and actually where do you think the
white king is going to park itself
ultimately is it going to kind of hang
out in the center go try to go queen
side as well
i think it's the the jury's out we we
haven't
uh made a firm decision yet i'm a little
well not a little i'm shocked that the
knight didn't hunt down this bishop and
nepo did not play knight c4
with the tempo against the queen but
simply put his knight on b3
why did he do that why is the knight
good on b3 do you think he can go to c5
okay well let's stop i was about to say
bishop f7
on the board but yeah you can just stop
what if you
what if you don't go to uh uh
uh c5 maybe he was worried about well
right now we would need to castle but if
we are we're castled we can
try greedy bishop d4 and knight b5
but even then you have queen b6
protecting everything
yeah that's super solid uh we didn't see
that move we did see
instead sorry not knight d4
we saw bishop f7 and now castle
played castles but by the way with that
variation like suppose now after castles
um you tried knight before oh he didn't
castle
no yeah yeah like i said it
the jury's still out on where white
wants to put his king and i think
nepo rightfully keeps his
options open he played the move queen f3
gen
assuming that he's got uh f4 bishop c5
is an answer
yeah and that also stops the knight from
coming to that magical d4 square
i really like that move right because
now we have queen 27
and so perhaps instinctually that's one
reason why you wanted to get 94 in while
you could
right before the before the queen uh
landed on f3
uh normally in those structures you want
your knight on d4
in like nine cases out of ten so i
didn't think it was that big a deal
but after the milk queen f3 uh lavonna
has a
little issue or two to deal with because
you know okay if you do play f4 bishop
c5 where exactly is the queen going
uh and now when i castle when i play a
part
castle long and play rookie one i feel
white's play is easier i'm not sure
where the queen belongs
yeah f6 provoking knight e4 that doesn't
look
like seven d7
yeah okay uh you got
you guys aren't going to be hating me
are you if i go bishop takes a seven
[Laughter]
no you you got to get it right i gotta
go bishop takes a7 i go oh no
what am i doing
[Laughter]
i leave my bishop on the hustler in me
what can i say bishop a7 i like that
it's not i mean it takes you a long
while uh
to hunt that guy down and maybe
uh
yeah i needed to try to take with a
knight at that point yeah it's because
oh at some point no no no no no so b6
a4 king b7 so i'm pinned
and now after a5 you can take with the
knight
and if i take on a7 with the king though
pawn takes b6
it's a double check looks like i'm gonna
lose this
king takes b6 i i can't imagine i can
survive that
forget it bringing another piece to the
party
much better sorry sorry you're
absolutely that that is
that that's uh that that's a factory
sign
yes oh you're having
well i was the one who started it with a
pawn grab by the way
uh not the move g6 not the move f4
uh f5 f4 lavon has played queen g6
okay and sean there was a reason why jan
uh kept uh the move kingside castles and
the vans
he wanted queen side castles after all
he was just faking us out jen he wasn't
going to castle
yeah understood i understood but you
know the thing about queen g6
is it covers a lot of things but i was
wanting to go knight g6
at some some position so that i could
threaten knight h4 and try to
remove
yeah and you know i had ideas of backing
it up with like f4 and f3
so it makes me a little sad that the
queen is sitting there and you know
there's so many pieces that could access
that square right
the bishop the knight and the queen well
it's kind of like a traffic jam right
everybody wants to go to the same square
exactly yeah yeah
by the way uh after castle f4 on the
board
he's on the board
piece you're winning the piece back and
and you're totally destroying me
the two pawns you took along
we have to stop that
um okay but you're still not threatening
to take and maybe i can
yeah a4 again well but now your rook's
not over there so
yeah i mean i would like to play uh
something
along the lines of rook takes e5 or
maybe d4
okay it's it's absurd it's fantasy chess
but okay we can do it uh just for fun oh
d4 looks really powerful
huh because the rook stop on me
yeah i if if we didn't do that he didn't
take the pawn though
yeah no no what did he do
bishop david after much thought trust me
he stared at that pawn for a while yeah
i am not like a blocking move so that i
can take your bishop the next move
bishop oh e4
if you take with the queen i then i take
right if knight takes
now um well
i i still have to reckon with nike
sticks back more fantasy variations but
i'm up a piece at least i mean
two well one i won't soon to be one
because you play queen b7 and queen a7
yeah
so i'm like the last time i found myself
in this variation
okay uh didn't happen we're having too
much fun
at uh poor levon aronian's expense uh
but uh bishop d2 was his choice
and uh uh jan's choice i i beg your say
beg your pardon five minutes four
minutes advantage for yon on the clock
as usual
by the way yes by the way something
really
like interesting in both of these games
take a look at the material distribution
here
right we have all the controls on and
just one pawn traded and now jump
and also white ahead on the clock
by four plus minutes gotcha now jump
over to the magnus game with wesley
juan paul all pieces on the board and
white ahead on the clock in this case
by what looks like seven well
he's got almost 19 minutes on his clock
yeah it is yeah seven minutes
magnus did something really strange at
move 11. i won't say
strange bad just strange different he
played the move knight g4
and after a couple of minutes bishop g5
brook to c8
bishop to h4 what looks like he's going
to bring his bishop to g3 and take a
look at this
nice d6 scrumptious button magnus drop
the knight back to f6
and 92 and remember we talked about this
knight not being a happy camper
on that square so that this f pawn can
push but
we now are in 14 moves in and magnus at
only 1104
on his clock we remember what happened
when he got into time pressure
last game he got disconnected that's
what happened
and he couldn't didn't have enough time
to reconnect
and reconnect so he has to be a little
bit careful i'd be
just a little concerned somebody's not
somewhere breaking up the norwegian
internet
system uh
my first take is black's in trouble
uh i'm seeing the knight coming i'm
seeing the knight
about to land big time against the d6
square i'm seeing bishop g3
i'm seeing a lot of harmony here on
white side of the
table uh what exactly is it that black
did with this knight g4 knight f6
uh loss of tempe uh you guys are the
great sicilian experts here
so help me out what is magnus going to
play
after this move knight d2 is it bishop
e7
the big plan that you can have is to
bring the knight off of d7 and put it
on e5 g6 uh
or e5 c6
uh you know in the case where he can't
take bishop takes f6
of course is this structure the router
structure
and you have to be ready to play it if
you're going to play a position like
this you're just ready to play this type
of structure
as it's just a well-known but what is
this structure called i feel like
browser oh no but like the name of the
pawn structure doesn't does it have a
name
the rouser
oh that's what it's called okay it looks
like richter rouser
it comes from the because it comes up in
that opening so frequently
it comes up all the time right yeah
because the knight okay
uh f6 and the bishop goes to g5 but
that's
history that's a strategic risk that uh
black would have to undertake it
doesn't he um after 95 to
to allow this uh doubling of his king
side
it is a rift it is a risk and it but it
is part of the structure as well as part
of
how you know what gets played the issue
of f4
f5 is typical for this structure black
will be you have to be ready to play
moves like h5
bishop to h6 uh will be
the kind of typical moves that happen
and
there you go i mean you're just going to
be in in super sharp land
in this right position right and it's
just
like that's the hand you and you've got
to play it that sharply
um boys played knight magnus has made
the move
so what what started from a rather tepid
quiet
uh opening has suddenly become explosive
and
how does it work can we just see what
happens after a crazy move like
f4 the knight has to go to g6 right
uh d5 oops i'm not allowing bishop c5
so you can't play d5 and threaten me
knight g6 bishop pawn queen
um greedy greedy uh
well i don't know i it's it's
it's a it's a great uh
position for ourselves as it's a
double-edged
game let's just go back by the way the
rook g8 move was quite strong
threatening bishop g7 in that position
as well yeah i i've already come into
those rouser positions a couple of times
usually it's white but i think i somehow
got myself into it as black a couple of
times
not me i don't remember why maybe like
in the night or
trying to avoid the main line of the
bishop g5 variations
you got your you outdid yourself
cleverly
i suffered through it a couple times
very good
sometimes we we all need uh
we all need seasoning there bishop d2
was when we left it
knight d5 queen e4
um taking advantage of his ownership of
the e4 square
queen f6 uh
these decisions are very intriguing i i
i don't know
why having the queens or not having the
queens and now
that we put the queen on a lesser square
i thought
the bishop might come to e4 when the
queen was on g6
we have queenie two and we're up to date
with the players
oh actually oh yeah you're right
lavon lavon by the way is spending a lot
of time isn't he he's spending a ton of
time he's almost down 10 minutes on the
clock
but i mean actually now just precisely
at
uh at nine minutes but
i mean the num the moves that had just
been played the fact that black got to
sneak in
f4 white was happy to see it because of
the the weakness on the e4 square
but this queen maneuver with queen to e4
to e2
i mean it's just it's just sophisticated
moves in right an
open position you normally don't see it
or at least semi-open position
you normally don't see that kind of
sophistication loss of time because
usually you need every tempo you can get
and let me just help uh
some of our viewers every viewer
on screen should be asking that why guys
tell me why didn't he develop his rook
and put pressure
there is a tactic in the position the
queen and bishop
could fall prey to a move like takes and
bishop d5 which would
basically provoke white to give up his
queen only for rook and a bishop
that is why um jan
dropped back with his queen he played
queen e2
i saw that there was a capture on c3
bishop takes c3
and knight d4 and bishop takes d4 pawn
takes i think we've caught up
with the players that's right and king
b1
um now played okay i can
i can now imagine in in a kind of uh
magnus carlsen like way you put your
bishop on e4 you put your queen back on
f3
you put your rook on e1 and you say i'm
gonna try to prove that this dark square
bishop's a bad
minor piece and i have a better minor
pieces
um is he right
yeah i'm trying to find the next three
moves for black
and it looks like
it looks like you don't have anything
with your bishops
well write home about that this is
really the key case and it's
especially the darkest bishop as you're
talking about how do i
pressure the position in any way maybe
can you
dare push your a pawn somehow
you want to play a5 but so you
you you're looking at something like
knight a5 bishop h
no uh mourinho right now i can't do it
because the beast right
but exactly i want to i want to
effectuate
if you want to go queen here push
disturbing your
your knight yeah something like [ __ ] for
example
uh maybe i returned the favor and just
uh
queenie five i've got this
and this covered now i i i don't like
by it just showed up as a thor in the
position oops
uh oh hitting jesus as well um
yeah well well for me the real question
if i'm black
is i really don't know what i'm going to
do with the dark square bishop
does it go here or here just give me
your favorite square
b6 if the bishop were on b6 wouldn't it
be passive that the bishop was on g7
yeah that's a beautiful diagonal g7
without with self counter chass
exactly that's what i was about to say
it would be great if you could capture
by the way uh lavon recognizing it's
not so easy did play g5
we wow why would you play bishop
oh the desirable rook e1 would provoke
bishop b4 okay
fine i would probably play a3 myself but
bishop e4
on the board h6 by lavon
i guess he was concerned that white
might try to crack
his king side structure with h4 queen
here and now i like your move very much
maurice i think
queen b6 is is crying to be played
queen v6 let's just this a5 plan seems
like black's only way
other than consolidating well it's
playing you're very
active right play something right to
play for some activity
and attack i don't see what else to do
with black
everything is is so linear again and
whoa
he's completely gone a different
direction he's play the move c6
blocking the or blunting the effect of
the bishop on the long diagonal
and instant replies from nepo h4
pure embracing the defensive in this
c6 nepo said let's go h4
and i've got 16 minutes and 15 seconds
on the clock you've got
5 47 and counting down this c6 move
i just now i'm really concerned for
black what are your next three or four
moves
given that you're not playing for any
activity anymore with the queen b6 idea
what maybe he can find another active
clan but i'm not happy with this bishop
that's sitting on f8 and its prospects
so the idea is after g
takes h4 we can play bishop f5 check
that's a nice one yeah i like that very
much
you're not losing a pawn in fact you're
gaining you you
uh double the h pawn so there's no
g5 takes h4 uh i think it's time
finally to get this push up into the
game uh
the problem that i saw with c7 c6 a move
i really didn't like
is that you're always leaving bishop
take c6
type of sacrifices uh available right
so for example bishop d6 your your queen
you know you take your eye off of the
pawn for just a single second
and then it's like uh oops i've allowed
the sacrifice maybe yeah and then after
ponzi 6
king v8 we finally get our knight into
the game with knight a5 yasser
exactly that knight on b3 is so woeful
right i mean i assume that's the winning
variation
uh that was the game yeah that was
definitely the intent
by the way i'm really stunned by the
move that lavon did play
uh we were just explaining don't take
the h4 pawn
guess what it lavon did he took the h4
pawn
thinks he's going to get a lot of tempi
yes because after bishop f5 check king
v8 queen f4 you do
hit me with bishop d6 although oh maybe
not because you can take on d4
yeah you can just take on b4 here and
then bishop e5
yep yeah it's not the end of the world
yet in the world
for me i still be careful
this pond it's messy it's messy but my
other point was if white doesn't go
queen b4 for some reason because i
didn't see that at first
but if bishop d6 if we decide not to
take that pawn in view of bishop e5
um then you know you're well that one
you have bishop d5 and i'm
i'm in trouble so i'd have to go back to
d2 but now you can start playing for h5
and suddenly that h4 pawn isn't weak at
all because
it's going to actually be potentially a
strength
yeah guys quickly i'm sorry i didn't get
a chance to say it when you guys please
jump
jump the position once one move back
when the bishop was on e4
yeah the bishop g6 idea is is winning
bishop d6 one back one back one back
back to the bishop on e4
oh bishop d6 right away yeah instead of
taking on h4
oh okay okay okay sorry yes please
taking on h4
bishop d6 takes takes this is the line
takes takes
takes knight c5 not knight a5 knight c
because knight a5 allows queen e7
knight c5 threatens mate on a6
nice as well and it's a double shot so
queen e7 doesn't work
and you're pinned so that's it
massive a massive improvement good eye
maurice i like it i like it okay that is
one reason why you don't play bishop d6
and that was perhaps a reason that
that lavon said i just don't like the
alternatives i may not like this
but i don't like the alternatives and
after this
let me just refresh my board i will be
right back
uh after takes on h4
oh he didn't play bishop af5 queen h3
with the nasty
threat of g5 discover check was
met by king c7 and
and well jan said
what's my problem i've got a great minor
piece
and this minor piece is going to be
great as well
but there it goes
but okay this is a bishops of opposite
color
that can only favor white i mean again
this bishop
very passive winning this is
now that bishop on g g5 might be a bad
disher but it's defending
good pawns or defending your pawns and
the only open file really is the e line
to try to exploit but rooks we're gonna
we're gonna go on that line and in this
position he actually decided to push
the pawn to f3 forcing king e1
that is a big time decision because
that pawn is is toast i mean
you know you're going to be upon down
you're you're you're never going to be
able to save this pawn
rook h3 and bishop f3 is on the board
it's coming
really fast rook h3 rook f4 bishop f3
rook f8 king e2 now again
can white win that position that's you
know
to be determined but but i mean the fact
that lavon
made this pawn sacrifice so quickly 15
minutes to three minutes guys
we're deep into the woods of an endgame
in that position
right back to the game between magnus
and wesley
and just as i'm speaking we are seeing
the end game appear
on the board but still with plenty of
pieces
and wesley has just collected the d6
pawn magnus willingly sacrificed what a
weird way
we even got here guys knight e5 was met
uh was meant earlier
by knight to d2 knight
no he had to go back one here right so
knight d to
95 no was bishop e7 you know he played
95. he went back
to f3 in the position
yeah right weird chess let's go forward
knight f3
went back and the magnus decided not to
repeat played knight c6
queen back bishop e7 he played bishop
takes on f6 and he took and here
it is we have an extra pawn we know that
bishop takes
c3 often happens to win back
this pawn to to crack the structure and
pru
and say well you don't really have
anything because your structure is so
compromised
is thinking about it with only four
minutes and 30 seconds left on his clock
to wesley's 1006. my my concern with
bishop c3 is that like if i play bishop
c3
generally i would be excited to you know
try to win
the c3 pawn um back and then have a nice
c pawn
and be playing against more islands but
the problem is i can't really move my
knight very easily because b6 is weak
so yeah more cramped than i would like
to be
considering the situation and the b file
is actually open
yeah that's gonna be one is actually
coming straight at you
right something like uh rook b1 next
right
but i know what you mean jen you you
you're really
how do you say uh revved up to play a
move like knight a5 so you can win c3 or
win e4 but
the problem is that rook b1 you know
this queen site is also being
eviscerated
and don't forget white started this with
the pawn up
um bishop takes f6 partying with the
dark square bishop
um does he have to do
that can he play move like maybe king e7
first you mean bishop c3 yeah like like
leave the bishop
leave that um leave that tempo for a
bump but
doubling rooks on the d file with the
threat of rook d7 will maybe you might
not see your pawn back you have to
just be a little careful if the the
trades oh
i see i i actually wanted to take with
the knight but i'm not
looking oh you don't have bishop takes
f3 because of the in-between move yeah
with check the old switching zoom yeah
okay so that's what
by the way while this is going on and
magnus is considering this
for all a lot of time he's down to 247
by the way minutes
but yeah i just wanted to jump quickly
to the game of ikaru nakamura one of the
favorites of this event
already lost one game and now against
the near dominion his position
is awful just he's just being stepped on
in this position
right now all although he's a pawn up
it's a double pawn but
he looks like he's upon her but he's no
but look at the active piece of sorry
maurice please i mean on screen
we have pentala hari krishna in place of
hikaru
oh right and now lanier employee we got
to get these
pictures these big images right because
now lanier is
that is not the real linear noise
playing himself
okay oh my goodness there you go all
right here we go
you're right uh i love white's position
a lot a lot this really looks uh
like white is having all the fun which
piece is not to like guys the rook
compared to the rook on h8 the king on
f4 is my favorite
compared to the kingdom of eight yes
outpost night on d6
and in the all junior battle oh yes
nothing being traded couple different
coupons but look at all these pieces on
the board 20 moves in
look at juniors like to play with the
pieces uh
maurice they they they they hit the home
runs you know
they they want to go for the attacks
this
is a crazy position again i'm
kind of favoring white just because
uh look at the pieces once more that
rook on a8 is buried
the bishop b8 needs a at least a move
to get back into the game and i
think knight e4 is the type of sacrifice
that i made many many many times
in my career to open up the bishop
and to to take advantage of
my superior development so i would say
that
white's for choice but time
is not a big factor
we can't even really study that one for
a long long time
by the way magnus after much cogitation
played
the move rook to d8 and
getting rid of his b6 yeah yeah decided
that he would resolve that
wesley traded on d8 king takes and then
played knight to d1
going hyper passive black has the two
bishops but white does have
the extra
well i've got the two bishops i've got
the two bishops
so what right
the problem is actually the pawn on e4
is a little bit
irritating um yeah
yeah yeah yeah if my knight if if this
night were on the c4 square
and i could comfortably defend my f pawn
pardon me my e4 bond with the f-pawn
then i'm groot i'm yeah you can have
your two bishops
good luck uh proving compensation but
here
i do have uh uh an issue
and i don't want to say it's full
compensation but
you know it's the e4 pawn
it's the e4 pawn that's a little bit of
a sore thumb it's real
by the way magnus now down to 135. this
is
unbelievable guys six on the clock now
what is he thinking
he's got he's got good cop maybe those
bishops are active white's pieces are
searching for coordination
but we know how much a factor time is
and he's only getting a five
second increment not a ten second one as
he did in the last
event that's the thing they got into the
flow of that 10 second increment and i
think
maybe it feels like they have a little
bit more time than they do
and if i'm wesley by the way i'm
thinking i'm not losing
i mean right right i'm not using the
position so
no if you're everybody now under a
minute as he is in this position
thanks i appreciate it seriously
and what could be magnus thinking about
i mean for me the most
direct and obvious move is 95 and just
saying
okay i'm opening up the position for my
bishop you're welcome to trade
do something about this and i'm going to
play rook seats
pardon me he did but what took him five
minutes
or two mate was he thinking about knight
a5
well there's a trade that's possible and
then somehow protect
your pawn on f on e4
be careful too because knight c4 hits
the bishop
so you could trade the knight now i'm
sorry what
i'm talking about the game position oh
apparently no apologies
knight a5 or something yeah okay and yes
you were saying knight c4 does
knight c4 because i'm trying to
anticipate your rook landing on the d2
square
exactly and then if your bishop moves
then the move
f3 and do you have anything to prove
or i should say maybe you have a lot to
prove what happens after f3
is b5 no not easy
that was the question right but take
stations
a3 and then i'm gonna
swoop in i don't know
swoop knight b5 king v6
that's a second pawn though i know it is
two pawns but i'm getting
oh you could go no you could just go
back let's face that i could take
okay i could just take it and then
because rook d2 can be met by rook c1
check fell by rook c2
unless you have a trick your king has to
also come in yeah i have a yeah i can't
i can't play the desirable uh king b6
because of knight
um c4 check so my king has to go to a so
some stupid square do you want and wait
rook d1 in that case trades rooks
as well although you do have bishop c1
at the end
yeah okay so some issues
two pawns though i mean yeah yeah that's
gonna be at least a pawn even if you win
one
back that's gonna be at least the pawn
so that looks like a reasonable
alternative for wesley
yeah and again jen uh it's not
the rapid chess time control that was
used
in the fischer nine
lx of 20 plus 10
but they are only getting five second
increments and as the world champion
gone use too much of his clock he's only
going to get five seconds that's not a
lot of bonus time
mm-hmm yep this is uh definitely going
to be difficult and it just makes me
nervous watching it because we know that
that
is part of the reason he ended up losing
um by disconnection
exactly i i believe at least i mean i
think levant
boy sorry oh go ahead no i want to move
to yeah i want to take a look at the
vaughn's position he's up a pawn and
[ __ ] of opposite color right
should be drawn is up upon her down his
pawn because when we left and he was
sacrificing they have the refund
holy smokes how how did he
oh my goodness okay well good for him
bishops of opposite color
[Music]
dead dead dead drawn or
yeah i mean it must be that looks like
drawn
yeah i i think it's dead that that talk
about dead talk about dead dead dead
go look at hikaru's game yeah and i was
going to say hi
though is playing on lanier's clock um
but i think lanier has just played this
nice
move looking c5 breakthrough move
to get the beautiful pawn on v6 what
about the h-pawn now
what about the h-bomb
what well he's going after he's going
after the b-pawn
but that h-pawn just looks so compelling
oh because you may knight out four jack
now could save it
knight f4 check king c4 king d7
i would have taken that pawn i was in
the i was in the square
i'm gonna have to do more well yeah of
course i mean
i do i'm gonna have to do more training
with lanier
lineard take the pawn okay king d3
uh okay this looks okay
95 exactly okay so why not okay so
i guess he wants to play king c2 yes
yes that's what he's done seven seconds
left
and now let's take the pawn please
yeah yes there it goes and now play king
b1 no no no oh
because you see united's shaking his
head
nakamura's shaking his head though he's
not happy right now knight
well
whoa what is this
oh he can't trade off that's the problem
you can't trade off knights
the b-pawn is fast and the h-pawn is
fast oh dear
oh this is terrible oh this technique
though was weird
no lanier is completely blown this he
didn't have to put his king on c3 he
could have gone king b1
kept his king out of oh
this is really really outside
so it was right here he took and if he
goes king b1
there's never any knight a4 check and
your next moves are really easy you're
just going to move your knight and go h5
and win the game
not to mention in worst case scenario
you can play e6 check and then you have
a third pass pawn
exactly you've got e6 on the now here
the other thing is why don't you just
play h5
you can't take the knight i've got past
pawns galore i've got e6 on tap
we've got b7 so he could have just
played h5
right with the threat of h6 yep
yeah and instead
the game has become
uh um jenna i'm told uh lavonne's
yeah game was a draw lavon and
um the pomnikki and lavon ronian have
drawn
so uh that gives uh lavon one half point
short of the broom which he did execute
in the 960.
right a nominal start two and a half out
of three
exactly and uh
let's see we've got i think we're gonna
have a number of draws in this round and
this one very surprisingly
you're right though that night that that
opportunity to play h5
and just run a run run with the pawn was
a big mess
but it was all about the time pressure
i'm in the game of the people
rod uh dominguez is basically playing on
increment
okay let's just uh jump back it looks
like
somehow when we left it magnus has
managed to win a spawnback there was a
trade on e5 knight c4
oh i think we were looking at f3 and not
e5 by wesley
e5 might have been overly committal and
oh well wesley just played 96 and said
uh draw well good things we have
we have the juniors game because now
it's a one minute game with
almost every single piece on the board
oops oh let's snap what happened
there uh don't get disconnected from the
accommodation
no i was about to say and you're good i
think you're good you could go back to
those games yeah
yeah there you go will in a second there
we go and we're looking for the the
junior games
yes yeah
you got it here we go holy cow
everything on the board after 27
minutes what are we gonna do okay
bishop take c4 was the last move okay
the the first
uh peace trade so
played right i mean i feel like in a
blitz game
i you know this game with a five second
increment
i mean who do you take here because
white has the beautiful control of the d
file but black's queen is sitting on h3
who has more cheapo potential
oh blacks she blacks mating potential is
the thing that
would scare me but wait wait a minute
yeah
something i saw the bar in the middle of
my board just went
and the computer says this was egregious
that was a potential back rank issue
well
but wait so you're saying like uh
if bishop takes e5 knight takes e5
rook takes to d8 take on c4 i can take
on c4 yeah
take well just a second let's not and
they get a game
because now what's happening and then 96
nine on c to d6 i apologize uh i
i would have to take like this also you
ever work in a piece
for a queen we're not seeing your guys
by the way
it looks like that's being played and
he's done and
what i've got is trade on e8 and take on
c4
with the idea of rook d8
and you can't stop rook d8 well
if i so if i play like a a luft move and
then i play queen h5 after you play rook
d8 like g6 makes sense h6
rook d8 queen h5 h5
99 knight d5
that's 99 no 92 95
uh allows queen f7 allows queen f7
92 prepares
yeah slowed me down hold on a second
okay yeah exactly as
this looks like a terrible construction
three oh but let's let's catch up with
them because this uh they're they're
playing
fast and furious with 11 seconds for
ferugia but
i i love that conception and he saw it
so quickly just
you know with 30 seconds left on the
clock bang bishop takes e5
going for this material imbalance rook
to d7 instead of rick v8 was played and
now
f4 looking to open some lines for the
queen
um as if you take with the g pawn it's
queen g4 winning your rock
so running a little mates
yeah and also just you know what whoa
queen c5 allowing knight
e4 with a gain of tempo but jeffrey said
yeah but my queen is good
um believe this i mean there are this is
they are playing
incredibly well for a 30 10 second game
i
i can't even believe it this is just
insane like
knight at six the idea between five the
queen before to save yourself it's crazy
but the uh the nice thing for
jeffrey is i thought he was going to
lose
a knight on the e8 square
and somehow by a miracle he rescued
himself
and now who's better and why wait like
because i can never lose the game i go
e4
bishop takes b7 i can never lose the
game but i do have rook g4
rook g8 and rook b8 ideas
why can't you never lose the game if i
get the a pawn and you get the b-pawn
like no i'm gonna give up my bishop for
your two pawns on the queen side
and i'll have rook and four versus uh
queen and two on the king side i'll have
a very easy fortress
oh harry krishna won as well and he's
going to jump in a tie
for the lead look at congratulations too
you know we didn't look at that game as
closely because there was so much going
on
and for a while it seemed rather
balanced but
the wheels definitely came off at some
point and ali
riza is just around allowed a three-time
repetition
which is a bit of a shame because i
think white
is better and should be playing on he
could have played rook g8
i would have played rook g8 myself and
just
gone for an ending that looks like this
where that's what you meant so you're
saying yeah
but i think that this was an
extraordinarily well played
wow wow great fight
yeah i mean we didn't get to see most of
it but
just imagine if they played that well
with 20 seconds left in the clock
imagine if they had 20 minutes
exactly
and we have a lavon aronian who is tied
for first he is with us
and hello lavonne congratulations and
having a very good day
hi guys hi
what happened today uh lavonne what was
your
most favorite game
uh well obviously my second game was the
brilliance
that's what we thought
nice this was of course uh
what we would call an opening disaster
what has gone wrong for you
in this uh opening where did the
i don't i don't really understand
because
sorry
you're breaking up on my audio uh lavon
oh yeah yeah sorry guys i'm i'm just
i'm just listening to tony which is
just good to do but uh okay now tony's
gone
so yeah i uh
can you hear me guys yeah yeah we can
hear you now
sorry sorry sorry so uh
yeah i thought the for some reason
that what i'm doing makes sense but then
uh
once i got this queen h4 check i
realized that
yeah i've missed uh i've missed a simple
tactic
at least i mean if i'm going for
something that's ridiculously dangerous
i should at least play b6 instead of ba
i mean not often so many lines
so i was very suicidal in that
particular game
but then i thought to myself okay
i will i will hang on i will do my
uh best and since uh sasha was
also in sort of sasha was in some sort
of a trout in time trouble
it was my hope and it worked out so
it was a very lucky break absolutely
propelled you to a tie for first in fact
yeah so lavon it looks like you've
changed uh
rooms from the 960 event
yes yes
well i'm i've changed not just the rooms
but also city
so i'm going to play
play something here while i'm playing
online so i'm i'm doing some
multitasking
so are you where are you then lavonne
i'm i'm in karlsruhe so i'm playing the
bundesliga
wow right ah
well another sport see see what wha what
a great game chess is
in our sports won't be able to take part
in one game and then follow it with
more games so oh money more money more
money more money
more money i'm talking
a little bit about your game your third
game
with nepo i've got it on my board i
don't know if you can
hopefully you can see it because this
this game
was really really confusing to us could
you just tell us what you
think was going on in this game
uh well i think
uh this is something that magnus played
against me with white in
i don't remember when we were playing
that game
and this is uh
i'm not sure i played 97 here
maybe i maybe i did but anyway
uh since i had good memories about that
game i think i won that one
i i wanted to repeat it and uh
here i think we were just over
complicating things
for not a particular reason
and then i decided to simplify with
knight c3 because i was a bit down on
time
i knew that night before is possible but
i just couldn't figure out all the you
know subtleties
so yeah knight db4 looks very tempting
because there are
some things hanging so then i told to
myself okay let's just
play safe because i think after knight
takes c3
my position should be rather solid
uh yeah i'm just playing g5 and then in
the worst
case i will just take this knight as it
happened
and then i'll i'll make a and since
we're playing a chess
where you are not allowed to capture
your own pieces
i can make uh
yes that did come up in the broadcast
yes and so i managed to
build some sort of a fortress and then
uh
i think uh jan played very dangerously
this king d2 idea was
extremely dangerous but then i was
down on time so i wasn't really able to
uh find the best solution for me
because i thought that the bishop ending
could be very dangerous for him but then
i forgot that i'm not in time to bring
my king to before
yeah yeah
i thought if i managed to get my king to
c5
you know and then well i was just
dreaming
which is being so delusional is
generally happening to me but especially
when i'm down on time
i'm i'm more delusional than ever
so overconfident wow so lavon you
briefly
uh referred to self-capture chess uh
as a you know aficionado of variants
um was that the one that appealed to you
the most as well as kramnik
yes i think that's the funniest one but
i think there has to be some adjustment
to that rule i think it's just a bit too
much when you can
block the pawn on b7 and then uh
somebody puts the
piece on c8 and it's finished i think
pawns shouldn't be allowed
to capture their own that's why they're
pawn you know
they
uh only only the big guys yeah only the
big guys are allowed to
capture everything the pawns should stay
like regular guys
is this something that you actually were
thinking about during the game like your
your mind actually goes in that
direction or it's only after the game no
no no i thought about this once they
introduced this and then
uh i think heine nelson showed this
uh bishop end game with bishop on c8 and
be taking c in promoting
and i said no no no this is too much and
the phones shouldn't have such a career
imagination running wild so the
bundesliga starts tomorrow right lavon
so you're saying you're gonna be playing
that in the morning and then this at
night
yeah wow um is that gonna do you think
that you'll be warmed up for the battles
or you might be a little tired
well it's not ideal but you know
contractual obligations are
one of those things that we have to
follow
wow it's good that you got off to a
great start lavon
and good luck tomorrow in all of your
tournaments
thank you guys thank you very much thank
you thank you thank you lavon
and here it is lavon aronian is tied
with harry krishna with five points
after three rounds wesley so and young
neformici also doing well with four
points
magnus carlson no doubt very
disappointed considering the disconnect
um should really be up there with the
leaders but it's magnus carlsen and
there's a lot of tournament left
to go so i have no doubt that he'll be
back up there competing for the top
spots
and here is our our co-leader hari
krishna
um what a day congrats on being tied for
the lead
thank you thank you uh can you hear me
perfectly okay
oh we're great you know it's good this
is like a phenomenal event so it's great
um it's great to see you you back in um
this
this competition uh yes
um i'm sorry um what was the the game
that stood out for you the most
today
uh i'm sorry uh can you repeat um what
was the game that stood out for you the
most today
uh i think okay the last game against
sasha was
not really a good game from me
uh i think uh it was doing quite well
i believe that he tried to win at the
end
um okay obviously it was uh
it was drawish but at some point white
was doing
really well um i think here
night no here black is okay actually
i think there was night before i moved
at some point i i missed it
uh but luckily he didn't play and
i don't know why he uh he could have
taken a draw anytime he wanted but
i think his loss from the previous game
might be the reason why he went all out
and how do you uh end up uh preparing
for a tournament like this
um obviously it's a unique situation
to play for this much money online so
tell us a little bit about what went
into the days before
yeah i was more concerned about my
internet you know
i think i think with online
the best preparation is to make sure
that your internet connection
uh is stable and you know you don't get
disconnected
but yeah i prepared as usually i played
some
over the board events uh in the month of
july and
august and i also had some practice
uh regarding online events
and of course it's great to see uh that
saint louis is having
this wonderful event i was actually
following uh
just uh just nine nine sixty
um so uh that was
uh sort of my uh you know practice you
know
try to guess the moves so and it was
also
about same time so uh it's really good
that
the 960 was before this so i could just
you know practice uh by guessing the
moves and stuff like that
uh so it's wonderful to see uh two great
uh events and of course uh uh you know
i i mean gary was playing so how could i
miss it so it was great
uh great watching that event and uh yeah
just great so
um go ahead maurice where are you right
now
and what time i mean i'm i i
i'm in prague otherwise i would be you
know half sleepy
like us when we did the india grand
chester coverage
um you mentioned backing up your
internet connection um does that mean
you have like multiple connections and
did you see what happened in magnus's
game
yeah i didn't understand uh what
happened because
i saw he he was doing quite well and
then
you know he lost the game and i was like
okay maybe there was some uh
result error or something like that but
then i
figured that it could be possible due to
uh disconnection no i i just have one
connection
uh but uh i'm not exactly playing
from my place but this is david
navarro's place so
uh since he has better connections so i
decided to
play from his place very smart
indeed well um huge start for you in
this event tied for first uh
good luck in the coming days thank you
so much thank you
congratulations hari thank you for
joining us good luck tomorrow
that was that was an incredible day of
chess guys i mean
obviously i wish magnus hadn't lost that
game by disconnect but other than that
uh
the excitement of the games i feel like
you couldn't have asked for more
no the amazing number decisive games
uh again time factor uh was featured
in a number of those uh those uh
decisive games but wow we've been really
uh
[Music]
it and uh tomorrow jen uh we'll be back
for more
that's right we've got rounds four
through six actually there were a lot of
draws in this last round yes but it felt
like there
were a lot of decisive games because
they were so wild
i have to say today
so much happened it's one of the only
days we've ever been
up doing a broadcast together that i
feel a little overwhelmed
like the content was so rich
in so many different places and then
crazy stuff going on
uh reverses reversals in game games that
you didn't expect or
magnus losing because of a disconnect
it just felt like so much happened today
that you want to back
up and say let me go over this day
slowly
let's actually go over all the games and
say what really happened in total
we didn't even get a chance to really
pay attention to the youngsters too much
exactly i just felt felt like uh
that the content is just incredibly rich
uh what happened today was like that so
hopefully
hopefully we can catch up a little bit
more with some other games as well
when starting with tomorrow yeah well
these guys are just playing some
extraordinary chess yeah you're right
there were so many rich games and um the
openings were so interesting i think
that we saw um just not a lot of
berlins and even the one that we saw
with nakamura was
a you know a tencent game that should
have been winning for dominguez and then
flipped around
um yeah and a lot of games going the
distance so
if it continues like this uh we are
going to be in for
um quite a few days here for the saint
louis rapid and blitz
oh and this is a little flashback to
a funny moment earlier in the day as
leslie you know hey
it's a busy time guys got him gotta
gotta get in here shaving that's right
i know what that's like very very nice
well
uh great start to what we anticipate
is and all know is going to just simply
be a great event
yeah so tune in tomorrow that's going to
be the same time that is 12 50
in st louis 150 on the east coast people
playing from
all over the world and we are going to
have our
second day of rapid chats on the st
louis
chess club rapid and blitz tournament
i'm jennifer shahady and i was here
today with yasser sarwan and maurice
ashley and we can't wait to see you
again tomorrow
thank you all for joining us good night
[Music]
you